Hey guys, it's Joel. Welcome to the Taproot Therapy Collective podcast. And this is going to be a little bit deeper of a dive. I've got a couple questions after the last essays that we did. Some of this will be a little bit of a retread because some of the questions, you know, said, hey, what's the real deal here? Is it more comprehensive than that? And so I'm going to be more comprehensive, which means I've got to go over some of the same stuff again. But this is a history of the DSM.
大家好，我是乔尔。欢迎收听 Taproot Therapy Collective 播客。这一期节目我们将进行更深入的探讨。在上一期文章发布后，我收到了一些问题。其中部分内容会是对之前话题的重述，因为有些问题问到：“嘿，这背后的真相到底是什么？有没有更全面的解释？”所以，我打算提供一个更全面的视角，这意味着我必须再次回顾一些旧内容。但这期节目是关于《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》（DSM）的历史。
And I think that it's one of the bigger questions that, I don't hear talked about much in psychotherapy. If something's coming up in therapy a lot or coming up with colleagues a lot, but I don't see people writing about it and talking about it, especially when therapists all agree on something and they're not talking about it. Those are the articles that I try and write. And in that vein, this is what this article is. So, you know, love it or hate it, there's this thing called the Diagnostic and Statistical
我认为这是一个在心理治疗领域很少被讨论的重要问题。如果某件事在治疗中频繁出现，或者在同行间经常被提及，但我却没看到有人撰写或讨论它，尤其是当治疗师们对某事心照不宣却避而不谈时，那正是我想要撰写的文章。基于此，这篇内容应运而生。所以，无论你喜欢还是讨厌它，都有一个东西叫做《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》。
Manual of Mental Disorders. And it's published by the APA. And it functions as this definitive classification system for the mental health conditions in the United States. So every diagnosis that we give, every insurance claim we file, every treatment plan that we have to justify with a soap note, and then you have to have a treatment plan to write, it all flows through this DSM categorical architecture. And that's part of the system. It's not something that you can really opt out of. So, you know, it is for all practical purposes, this Bible of American psychiatry.
它由美国精神医学学会（APA）出版，作为美国心理健康状况的权威分类系统。我们给出的每一个诊断、提交的每一份保险理赔、每一份必须通过 SOAP 笔记来证明合理性的治疗计划，以及你必须撰写的治疗计划，所有这些都遵循 DSM 的分类架构。这是系统的一部分，你无法真正选择退出。所以，实际上，它就是美国精神病学的“圣经”。
And yet the fact that we have to diagnose under its criteria is one of the most controversial issues that I've encountered in the field, which is weird because, you know, everybody has. has to do it. Yet a lot of people off the record will tell you that they don't really like it or don't really care, which itself, you know, should indicate a problem when the clinical rules are different than the clinical judgment on a level like that. And I'm not picking a huge side. I'm not saying that we should throw out all diagnostic criteria or that, you know, if you diagnose anybody, you're pathologizing them or some of the arguments that people think that I should make. Not that they're right or wrong. I'm just, I'm undecided and I'm always trying to acquire new perspectives and new information.
然而，我们必须根据其标准进行诊断，这却是我在这一领域遇到的最具争议的问题之一。这很奇怪，因为每个人都必须这样做。但私下里，很多人会告诉你他们并不喜欢它，或者根本不在乎。当临床规则与临床判断在这一层面上出现分歧时，这本身就说明存在问题。我并不是要选边站，也不是说我们应该抛弃所有诊断标准，或者说只要你给某人下诊断就是在将其病理化——尽管有些人认为我应该持这种观点。我并不是说他们对或错，我只是还没下定论，我一直在努力获取新的视角和信息。
But, you know, to understand, I definitely have critiques of the DSM. And one of those is that it doesn't really have any sort of unifying singular vision, which means that it becomes a very hard lens to use because it doesn't know how it wants to conceptualize anything. And that happens for a lot of different reasons. So one of the things that, you know, I want to make an argument about is like, I'm not, I want to refute is I'm not arguing against science. I'm not arguing against evidence-based practice.
但是，要理解这一点，我确实对 DSM 有所批评。其中之一是它缺乏一种统一的单一愿景，这使得它成为一个非常难以使用的视角，因为它不知道自己想要如何概念化任何事物。这种情况是由多种原因造成的。所以，我想申明的一点是，我并不是在反对科学，也不是在反对循证实践。
I'm pointing out places where the science that we assume is scientific might not be very scientific, which is not an argument for pseudoscience. It's an argument for introspection and reflection. And we should do that, you know. We should have those conversations. So the DSM-1, you know, it starts with this kind of dynamic paradigm where, you know, Everybody's talking in the post-World War II era on the basically the language of like, you know, Freud and Jung still. There's neuroses and there's reactions and there's these dynamic processes that we don't necessarily use to conceptualize things with diagnosis anymore.
我指出的是那些我们认为科学但可能并不那么科学的地方，这并不是在为伪科学辩护，而是在呼吁内省和反思。我们应该这样做，我们应该进行这些对话。DSM-1 始于一种动态范式，在二战后的时代，每个人基本上还在使用弗洛伊德和荣格的语言。那时有神经症、反应，以及我们现在不再一定用来进行诊断概念化的动态过程。
But it's trying to describe those in a statistical manual. And so it's talking about sort of balancing forces, you know, the language of psychoanalysis, more or less. And so that nomenclature explicitly used the term reaction for many conditions, like a schizophrenic reaction. So it was more in communication with the environment to doing something to a person than a person just kind of doing something in a vacuum, which is one of my criticisms of what the DSM looks like now. You know, a depressive reaction. They're assuming that this is reacting to something either internal or external. So it's a part of a system, which is, you know, probably a better way to do it. And so it reflected this belief that the symptoms were manifestations of this patient's struggle to adapt.
但它试图在统计手册中描述这些内容。所以它讨论的是某种平衡力量，也就是精神分析的语言。因此，该命名法明确地为许多疾病使用了“反应”一词，例如“精神分裂症反应”。这更多地是在与环境进行互动，对人产生某种影响，而不是一个人在真空中做某事，这也是我对 DSM 现状的批评之一。比如“抑郁反应”，他们假设这是对内部或外部事物的反应。所以它是系统的一部分，这可能是一种更好的处理方式。它反映了这样一种信念：症状是患者适应过程中的挣扎表现。
Again, that's a conceptualization that I like. That's why I'm not saying that we should do psychoanalysis again or classical union analysis. That's something that I write about because I use elements of it, but it's not something that I do. So, you know, that's not what I'm making a case for it. I'm saying that there are useful things of that model that we have lost. Like a neurosis was not the separate, you know, species of existence, but it was an exaggeration of a normal defense mechanism. And so that's why some of that language is now inevitably coming back as trauma becomes this focus.
再说一次，我喜欢这种概念化。这就是为什么我不是说我们应该重新进行精神分析或古典荣格分析。我写过这个话题，因为我使用了其中的元素，但这并不是我的执业方式。所以，我并不是在为它辩护。我是在说，那个模型中有一些我们已经丢失的有用东西。比如，神经症并不是一种独立的生存物种，而是正常防御机制的夸大。这就是为什么随着创伤成为焦点，一些术语不可避免地回归了。
You know, if you look at the history of mental health initially kind of like in the 60s, all of this focus was on schizophrenia. Like that was the most interesting thing ever and it sucked up all the money. And then autism became incredibly trendy. I guess ADHD in the 90s. And then all of a sudden, you know, in the 2000s it was autism and that sucked up. up, you know, all the money. And then the next big thing was trauma. Now, you know, trauma and PTSD and what those are and how we should think about them is the huge conversation.
如果你回顾一下 60 年代心理健康的历史，最初所有的焦点都在精神分裂症上。那是最有趣的事情，吸走了所有的资金。然后自闭症变得非常流行。我想 90 年代是 ADHD。突然间，在 2000 年代，自闭症成了焦点，吸走了所有的资金。接下来的大事是创伤。现在，创伤和 PTSD 以及我们应该如何看待它们，成了巨大的讨论话题。
And, you know, that diagnostic criteria in the DSM 1 and 2, they weren't lists of symptoms, but they were narrative paragraphs. They were short descriptions of a prototype that the clinician was expected to match against a patient's presentation in the room. So the psychiatrist's judgment was what made it. You know, do you feel like these fours, forces are present. And this relied on interpretive skill and theoretical orientation. No one's going to ever be 100% competent. But most people who have gone through this process probably understand how to talk to somebody and figure out what is going on. That's another thing that modern DSM doesn't really like. It doesn't want you to use that subjective judgment. And my point,
而且，DSM-1 和 DSM-2 中的诊断标准不是症状列表，而是叙述性段落。它们是对原型的简短描述，临床医生需要将其与患者在诊室中的表现进行匹配。所以，精神科医生的判断才是关键。你是否觉得这些力量存在？这依赖于解释技巧和理论取向。没有人能做到 100% 的胜任，但大多数经历过这个过程的人可能都懂得如何与人交谈并弄清楚发生了什么。这是现代 DSM 并不真正喜欢的一点。它不希望你使用那种主观判断。而我的观点是，
a lot of my point with this piece and a lot of other pieces is that subjective judgment is completely inevitable. And because of it is completely inevitable, when you say, oh, here's a purely objective or logical system, what you've done is hidden the subjectivity from yourself, and then you don't know what it is. And that's a problem, because it was somewhere. And I think that's what's happened now in the DSM-5. So like Freudian psychoanalysis, it might interpret like a patient's silence as resistance, rooted in an anal retentive personality structure. Or while a psychiatrist with a more biological or social orientation who's medicating now they may just see that differently with good reason
我这篇文章以及其他许多文章的核心观点是，主观判断是完全不可避免的。正因为它是不可避免的，当你声称“这是一个纯粹客观或逻辑的系统”时，你实际上是将主观性隐藏了起来，以至于你自己都不知道它是什么。这是一个问题，因为它依然存在。我认为这就是现在 DSM-5 中发生的情况。比如弗洛伊德的精神分析，可能会将患者的沉默解释为阻抗，根源于肛门滞留型人格结构。而一个更倾向于生物学或社会学取向、正在进行药物治疗的精神科医生，现在可能会有充分的理由以不同的方式看待它。
I mean not all silence is resistance you know there's a lot of things that could cause that and now that the field has matured scientifically in the technique I think that the underlying conceptualization of the manual is not helping us use those techniques as well so while this approach offered this rich, you know, humanistic and individualized view of suffering, it also failed this fundamental test of science, which is reliability. And that refers to just consistency of measurement. You know, if two patients see the same psychiatrist, I mean, if two psychiatrists see the same patient, they should have the same diagnosis. But a lot of people were just wrong. And, you know, doctors are kind of loathe to criticize each other publicly. A lot of
我的意思是，并非所有的沉默都是阻抗，有很多因素会导致这种情况。现在该领域在技术上已经科学成熟，但我认为手册背后的概念化并没有帮助我们更好地运用这些技术。因此，虽然这种方法提供了一种丰富、人文且个性化的痛苦观，但它也未能通过科学的基本测试，即信度。这指的是测量的一致性。如果两个精神科医生看同一个病人，他们应该得出相同的诊断。但很多人就是错了。而且，医生们通常不愿公开批评彼此。很多
that's for liability. And a lot of it's for, you know, being at the top level of hierarchy. They don't want to be seen, you know, fighting too loudly. And so they don't like to disagree. And because they don't like to disagree, um, they didn't like to say, well, you're the wrong one and you're the incompetent one or, you know, whatever. And so this, the most famous of this was this US, UK diagnostic project. And it compared these diagnostic practices in New York and London. And they found that American psychiatrists diagnosed schizophrenia of much more than the British ones. And they were, they were likely, the British psychiatrists were likely to diagnose manic depressive illness, uh, bipolar, is bipolar disorder now for the same clinical presentation. You know, if the symptoms and the case
原因是为了规避责任。还有很多是因为处于等级制度的顶端。他们不想被看到在激烈争吵。所以他们不喜欢产生分歧。因为不喜欢分歧，他们不喜欢说“你是错的，你是无能的”等等。最著名的例子就是美英诊断项目。它比较了纽约和伦敦的诊断实践。他们发现美国精神科医生诊断精神分裂症的频率远高于英国医生。而英国精神科医生更有可能对同样的临床表现诊断为躁郁症（现在的双相障碍）。你知道，如果症状和案例
study look relatively the same, they would have a different diagnosis. So it demonstrated that schizophrenia in the DSM2, it wasn't like a stable biological entity, but it was sort of culturally and theoretically dependent. And I would argue that that is because psychosis is a whole lot about culture and technology and the metaphors we draw from those. I've argued that. And if you look up the ritual and animism piece, that's a deeper dive on that. There's a podcast and there's a blog. on it, looking at how psychosis changes based on culture and it changes over time because you're dealing with deep metaphors of the brain, which a lot of times are mystical and religious and highly symbolic and symbols are not universal and symbols are not completely biological.
研究看起来相对一致，他们却会给出不同的诊断。这表明 DSM-2 中的精神分裂症并不是一个稳定的生物学实体，而是某种程度上依赖于文化和理论。我会争辩说，这是因为精神病在很大程度上与文化、技术以及我们从中汲取的隐喻有关。我曾论证过这一点。如果你查阅关于仪式和万物有灵论的文章，那里有更深入的探讨。有一个播客和一篇博客专门讨论这个问题，研究精神病如何根据文化而改变，并随着时间推移而演变，因为你处理的是大脑深层的隐喻，这些隐喻往往是神秘的、宗教的且高度符号化的，而符号并非普世的，也并非完全是生物学的。
So of course psychosis is going to change. So this collapse of reliability was not just this academic embarrassment. It was an existential threat to psychiatry. So without reliable diagnostic systems, epistemology, epidemiology of just studying the, and that's the reason the DSM exists is they want to study diseases, but mental health is messy. It's not cancer or the flu. It's, I don't know, some anxiety, some depressions. How do you group these things together? Big problem. I'm not saying that I have a perfect answer here. I'm just sort of critiquing and offering my perspective,
所以精神病当然会改变。因此，这种信度的崩溃不仅仅是学术上的尴尬，更是对精神病学的生存威胁。没有可靠的诊断系统，流行病学就无法研究疾病。DSM 存在的理由就是为了研究疾病，但心理健康是混乱的。它不是癌症或流感。它是焦虑、抑郁等。你如何将这些东西归类在一起？这是个大问题。我并不是说我这里有完美的答案。我只是在批评并提供我的视角，
but the researchers couldn't count how many people had a disorder if they couldn't agree on what the disorder was. So there's already sort of this feud there where people always feel like somebody else is doing it wrong. So inner R.D. Leng, who's a Scottish psychiatrist, really interesting guy, very understudied. I've never heard another colleague talk about him, and I think he's a fascinating person. But he, um, not just in the things I mentioned here, he should look up some of his schizophrenia stuff, but, you know, he writes the divided self and he argues that what looks like
但如果研究人员无法就疾病的定义达成一致，他们就无法统计有多少人患有某种疾病。所以这里已经存在一种纷争，人们总是觉得别人做错了。因此，苏格兰精神科医生 R.D. 莱恩（R.D. Laing），一个非常有趣且被严重低估的人。我从未听过其他同事谈论他，但我认为他是一个迷人的人。但他，不仅是在我提到的这些事情上，你应该去看看他关于精神分裂症的研究，他写了《分裂的自我》，并认为看起来像
madness was often a sane, intelligible strategy, um, for surviving unlivable situations in the past that's still happening. So he had a more trauma informed. A lot of these guys did, pretty early in the 60s. They had a more modern trauma-informed thing where it wasn't a moral deficiency or a lot of the things that people posited or bad genes. You know, they weren't eugenicists. And so Lange posited that the schizophrenic person was not a broken machine, but they were an existential voyager and they were entering the deep mind. And he suggested that bizarre speech and behavior of the psychotic patient were coded mechanisms about double binds that were put on society or put on the individual.
疯狂的东西，往往是一种理智的、可理解的策略，用于在过去生存于无法忍受的环境中，这种情况至今仍在发生。所以他有一种更具创伤知情的视角。在 60 年代，很多这样的人很早就有了这种观点。他们有一种更现代的创伤知情视角，认为这并非道德缺陷，也不是很多人所假设的基因问题。他们不是优生学家。因此，莱恩认为精神分裂症患者不是一台坏掉的机器，而是一个存在主义的航行者，正在进入深层心灵。他认为精神病患者怪异的言语和行为是关于社会或个人所受到的“双重束缚”的编码机制。
And there is some truth to that because when a person is given a false choice as a child, you know, it's called a double bind or by a society where it's like, you know, work hard and be successful. But if you're not successful, you're not working hard enough because the system's never wrong and I can never get ahead. I'm kind of being gaslit to a point where I feel like the problem when I'm really not. Same thing with a parent that's like, you know, always speak your mind and I want to know who you are and why you're being silent. And then you tell them and they're like, well, I don't like that's the wrong thing. That's not who you are.
这确实有一定道理，因为当一个孩子被给予一个虚假的抉择时，这被称为“双重束缚”；或者被社会给予这种抉择，比如“努力工作就能成功，但如果你不成功，就是因为你不够努力”，因为系统永远不会错，而我永远无法出头。我被煤气灯效应（gaslighting）操纵到一种程度，让我觉得问题出在我身上，而实际上并非如此。父母也是一样，他们说“说出你的想法，我想知道你是谁，为什么你保持沉默？”然后当你告诉他们时，他们却说“我不喜欢这样，这是错的，那不是你。”
you know you get all of these things emerging in psychoanalysis where they say okay there's a a dream of an object in a patient's mouth and i'm doing the dream analysis and they say the object is glass and if they but they're choking they can't breathe but if they swallow it then they swallow this glass bottle and they're keeping it inside it's too much and if they get it out of their mouth they have to break it and then they get it wounds them you know and this is really about the double bind that they were placed on in childhood because if they were said who they were their real self if it came out then they were wounded like the glasses wounding them but if they swallowed it and kept it inside then it was too much and they weren't living authentically and
你知道，在精神分析中会出现所有这些东西，他们说，好吧，有一个梦，梦见患者嘴里有一个物体，我正在进行梦境分析，他们说那个物体是玻璃，如果他们吞下去，他们会窒息，无法呼吸；但如果他们吞下去了，他们就吞下了这个玻璃瓶，它留在体内，太沉重了；如果他们把它从嘴里拿出来，他们必须打碎它，然后它会伤害他们。这实际上是关于他们在童年时期所处的双重束缚，因为如果他们说出自己是谁，真实的自我如果显露出来，他们就会像被玻璃伤害一样受伤；但如果他们吞下它并留在体内，那又太沉重了，他们无法活得真实。
because their parents and mommy put them in this position that's why now they have schizophrenia but this trauma led to this split well now we know that schizophrenia is pretty genetically determined trauma can set it off it certainly doesn't help so can certain drugs we think maybe they just raise the age of onset or lower the age of onset too earlier, but you would have gotten schizophrenia anyway, maybe a little bit of both. These early guys didn't think of schizophrenia that way. They thought it was completely determined by the environment. Now we act like it's completely determined by the genes. We need to meet in the middle here. You know, there's a part of my critique of my profession is that it's always overreactions to a problem that go too far in the
因为他们的父母把他们置于这种境地，这就是为什么他们现在患有精神分裂症。这种创伤导致了这种分裂。好吧，现在我们知道精神分裂症在很大程度上是由基因决定的，创伤可以诱发它，当然它没有帮助；某些药物也可能如此，我们认为它们可能只是提高了发病年龄，或者降低了发病年龄，但无论如何你都会患上精神分裂症，也许两者兼而有之。这些早期的研究者并不那样看待精神分裂症。他们认为它完全是由环境决定的。现在我们表现得好像它完全是由基因决定的。我们需要在中间找到平衡。你知道，我对我的职业的批评之一是，它总是对问题做出过度反应，每次都走向错误的极端。如果你回顾心理治疗的历史，它们在各个方向上曲折前进。所以，那种视角在当时让主流精神病学感到恐惧，因为当时的主流精神病学在很大程度上是种族主义和优生主义的，并且沉迷于道德。所以你的基因失败了，或者你的坚韧度不够。你不如别人强。他们认为这是患者的错。患者是错的。因此，患者的妄想实际上是一种诗意的真理。这是荣格的观点。而精神病学试图用药物或电休克疗法来治愈他们，这并非医疗上的仁慈，而是一种政治暴力，试图压制
wrong direction every time. And they kind of zigzag everywhere if you look at the history of psychotherapy. So, you know, that perspective was terrifying to mainstream psychiatry at the time, which was, you know, largely pretty like racist and eugenicist and, um, and, uh, obsessed with morality. So your genes had failed or your, you know, fortitude. You were, you know, not as strong as somebody else. They saw it as this, the patient's fault somehow. The patient was wrong. Um, and so the, the patient's delusions, you know, are actually a poetic truth. You know, that's kind of the Jungian take. And psychiatry is a attempt to cure them with drugs or shock. therapy, it was not medical benevolence. It was this political violence where you're trying to repress
某人。然后托马斯·萨斯（Thomas Szasz），在 1960 年，萨斯说，莱恩是从左翼出发的。他是社会主义者，热衷于存在主义，以及拉康和法兰克福学派的东西，基于他的写作。我不知道他是否亲口说过。我不认为他引用过拉康，至少我没读到过。不过我没读过莱恩的所有作品，所以我不知道。总之，萨斯更偏右翼。他像个自由意志主义者，就像“离我的草坪远点”。我想在我的土地上种大麻，拥有很多枪，我想在我的土地上做什么就做什么。这就是他的取向。所以这是一个更偏右翼的论点，但表达的是同样的事情。
somebody. And then Thomas Zazz, you know, in 1960, Zaz says, you know, Ling is kind of coming from the left. He's a socialist and into existentialism and, you know, Lecon and Frankfurt School stuff, probably, based on his writing. I don't know that he's ever said that. I don't think he cites Lecon anywhere that I've read. I haven't read all of Ling, though, so I don't know. Anyway, so, you know, Zaz is more right-wing. He's like a libertarian, like get off my lawn. I want to grow marijuana and have a bunch of guns and I can do whatever I want on my land. That's kind of, you know, his orientation. So it's more of a right-wing argument saying the same thing.
他说，疾病是身体结构或功能的偏差。而心灵不是一个物理器官。它只是一个概念。所以它不可能有病理学。心灵不可能有疾病。只有生活方式的问题。如果你改变你的生活方式，你可以做得更好。你也许需要服药，
And he says, you know, illness is a structural, functional deviation of the body. And the mind is not a physical organ. It's just a concept. So it can't have a pathology. You know, there can be no illness of the mind. There's only problems in how you live. And if you change how you live, you can do better. You maybe need to take medication.
你也许需要换个角度思考。你可能，你知道，这总是关于你应该能够控制的事情，这是一种“靠自己努力”的右翼思想，但它也和莱恩这样的左翼人士做出了同样的论证。萨斯认为精神病学是伪科学，被国家用来监管社会异见者。他可能是在关注对边缘群体的迫害，这在当时通常不与右翼联系在一起，
you maybe need to think differently. You may, you know, that it's always about something that you should be able to gain control over, which is, you know, kind of a bootstraps right-wing thing, but it's also sort of making the same argument as a lefty like Leng. Zaz's contending that psychiatry was the pseudoscience, and it was used by the state to police social deviants. He, you know, is sort of, you know, maybe looking at, the persecution against outgroups, which is not typically associated with the bright wing, at
至少现在不是，但是，将行为贴上疾病的标签，或者社会在逃避处理冲突的艰巨道德工作，他们只是把人带走，这样他们就不必真正弄清楚如何将这些人融入社会，为人类真正的多样性留出空间。所以这种精神疾病的标签允许国家监禁无辜的人。所以萨斯是一个右翼人士。他更多是关于“你剥夺了我的自主权”。他不像莱恩那样热衷于集体主义和关系能量。
least now, but, you know, labeling behaviors such as illnesses or society that is, you know, avoiding these difficult ethical work of dealing with conflict, that they're just sort of taking people away so they don't have to actually figure out how to integrate them into society and do something with them and make room for like the real diversity of humanity. And so this mental illness label allowed the state to just incarcerate innocent people. And so Zaz is a right-wing guy. He's more about, you're taking away, you know, my freedom of autonomy. He's not as much into it for the collectivism and relational energy of Leng.
但他们大多提出了相同的论点。所以罗森汉（Rosenhan）提供了这种实证说服力。自从上次之后，我查阅了更多关于罗森汉的信息，因为你们都问了。但在 73 年的研究中，他在《科学》杂志上以《在精神病院里保持理智》为题发表了文章。或者说标题是这个。这是一个社会学实验。
But they mostly make the same argument. So Rosenhan, he provides this empirical conviction. And I looked up more information about Rosenhan since the last one because you all asked. But in the 73 study, You know, he publishes in science under the name on being sane in insane places. And, or the title, not the name. Yeah, he didn't, it wasn't pseudo eponymous or however you say that. So anyway, it was this sort of sociological experiment.
一个你今天可能永远无法做的实验。他说他找了八个伪病人，就是假装成病人的人。他们是理智的，因为他们是学生。他们没有任何精神疾病史。其中包括一名心理学研究生、一名儿科医生、一名精神科医生、一名画家、一名家庭主妇，他们的指令非常精确。我们希望你去精神病院的入院处，抱怨
One that you probably could never do today. So he says he's getting eight pseudo-patients, just people to pretend to be patients. And they're sane because they're students. And they have no history of mental illness at all. And it includes a psychology graduate student, a pediatrician, a psychiatrist, and a psychiatrist, a painter, a housewife, and their instructions are super precise. You know, we want you to present to the psychiatric hospital admissions office and complain
听到声音。这些声音是不熟悉的。它们和你性别相同。它们只说三个词：空（empty）、虚（hollow）、砰（thud）。这就是你要说的。除此之外，那个单一的捏造，那只是一个谎言。
of hearing voices. And the voices are unfamiliar. You know, it's not something you know. They're of the same gender as you. And they only say three words, empty, hollow, and thud. That's all you say. They say. And beyond that single fabrication, that's just one lie.
他们能够对其他所有事情完全诚实。你现在听到声音了吗？有什么？没有其他损伤。他们只是说，有一次我听到了“空、虚、砰”。这是经过计算的，因为他知道精神科医生并不真正倾听，或者并不真正遵循手册中声称他们应该调查的许多事情，这种情况至今仍在发生。
They're able to be completely truthful about everything else. Are you hearing the voices now? What do? there's no other impairment. They just say, you know, one time I heard empty hollow thud. And this was calculated, you know, because he's knowing that the psychiatrist don't really listen or don't really follow a lot of the things that it says that they're supposed to be investigating, which still happens.
他们只是给你贴上一个诊断标签。他试图做的是让医疗系统更彻底，并说，好吧，我们只是在随意对待人们，让他们出院，让他们入院又出院，但我们需要真正与人们坐下来治疗他们。而当前的利润驱动系统，它的演变方式，并不奏效。所以我们需要花更多时间。他试图让它做一些好事。
You know, they kind of slap a diagnosis on you. And he's kind of, what he's trying to do is make the medical system more thorough and say, okay, well, shoot, you know, we're just kind of slapping people around and discharging them, and slapping them in and slapping them out. but we need to actually sit with people and treat them. And the current sort of profit-driven system, the way it's evolving, is not working. So we need to spend more time. Like he's trying to get it to do something good.
但当你让一个有问题的人感到不安全时，很多时候他们不会做正确的事。他们只是做一些防御性的事情，这就是发生的情况。所以选出了 12 名心理学学生，他们进去后，所有 12 人在说这些话时都被收治了。他们对其他一切都很诚实。唯一的谎言是“我听到空、虚、砰，被一个声音说出来”。
But when you make somebody who has a problem insecure, a lot of times they don't do something good. They just do something to deflect, which is what happens. And so 12 students are selected, 12 students of psychology, and they go in and all 12 are admitted when they say this. And they're honest about everything else. The only lie is I heard hollow doll thought, be sad by a voice.
标签有一种粘性。一旦他们被标记为精神错乱或患有精神分裂症——我不是说精神分裂症患者是精神错乱的，这是他文档中的语言——一旦这些伪病人被收治，他们就不再有任何症状。他们说话正常，行为合作，告诉工作人员他们感觉很好。
And there was this sort of stickiness to the label. Once they were flagged as insane or having schizophrenia, I'm not calling people schizophrenia as insane. It was, you know, his language and his document, is that, like, once these pseudo-patients are admitted, they cease having any symptoms. And they spoke normally, they behaved cooperately, they told the staff they felt fine.
然而，整个工作人员被这个标签蒙蔽了，将他们的正常行为重新解释为病态，这就是重点。他试图说，当你让诊断变得主观，而人们有偏见时，他们就会顺手使用这些偏见，而科学的作用应该是从心理学程序中消除偏见。所以当伪病人记录他们的经历时，护士在图表中记录了这一点：“患者从事这种写作行为。”他们将其解释为精神分裂症的强迫性症状，但实际上那只是一个无聊的家伙。所以，他在日记中写下这些，因为他要在精神病院待上一周。然后，无聊引起的走动，因为他们无聊，被视为神经质的紧张不安。医生每天与他们的平均接触时间约为六到八分钟。重点是让他们在出院时拿到医疗记录，这样他们就能看到每个人对他们的评价，这些评价很可能被当时精神病学所使用的那种心血来潮的判断所影响。
Yet the whole staff, blinded by this label, reinterpreted their normal behavior as pathological, which was the point, is that he was trying to say that when you make this subjective and people have biases, then they just go ahead and use those biases subjectively, which the role of science is supposed to remove bias from procedure in psychology. So when pseudopacients took notes on their experiences, nurses recorded this in the chart. The patient engages in this writing behavior. And they interpreted it like it was this compulsive symptom of psychosis, but it was really just a dude who was bored. And so, he's writing down in his journal because he's going to be in a mental institution for the next week. And then, you know, boredom induced walking because they're bored, was seen as a nervous agitation that they were neurotic. And the average daily contact with the doctor was about six to eight minutes. You know, the point is for them to get their medical records when they get out so that they can see what everyone was saying about them that, you know, would probably be colored by just these kind of whims that psychiatry was using at the time.
请记住，这是一所医院。诊所里可能正在进行相当不错的心理学工作，但他试图说医院应该表现得更像治疗诊所或个人治疗师的办公室，当然，即使你证明了这一点，医院也不会这样做。因为那会很昂贵。所以，这些病人从未被宣布理智或被误诊。在他们无法再表现出精神分裂症症状后，医院什么也没承认，
And keep in mind, this is a hospital. There was probably pretty good psychology happening in clinics, but he was trying to say that hospitals should act more like a therapy clinic or an individual therapist's office, which, of course, a hospital is not going to do, even when you prove something like this. So, because it would be expensive. So, you know, these patients were not ever declared sane or misdiagnosed. The hospital admitted nothing after they could get no more symptoms of schizophrenia,
如果你有精神病发作，即使是在前驱期，你也会在这些人被收治的时间段内看到行为，他们被收治了 19 到 52 天。所以他们向任何使用当时那种相当宽松、非清单式系统的人提供了他们没有精神分裂症的证据。对于患有这种精神疾病的人来说，在没有任何药物的情况下入院 52 天而没有出现另一个症状，这是不可能的。所以标签不起作用。
which if you have a psychotic break, even if you're in the pro-dromal period, you're going to see behavior over the amount of time that these people were admitted, and you were from 19 to 52 days. So they were providing evidence that they did not have schizophrenia to anybody who was using even the pretty loose, you know, non-checkless-based system at the time. There was just, there's no way for somebody who has mental illness like that to go in for 52 days and not have another single symptom without any medication. So the label didn't work.
但他们从未说“哦，哎呀，我们犯了个错误”。他们只是说“哦，现在处于缓解期了”。好吧，它是怎么缓解的？这甚至在他们当时对诊断的了解下也说不通。所以，罗森汉的结论相当凄凉。他说，导致诊断的显著特征存在于患者的环境中，而不是患者自身。他证明了这一点，当他把直觉专家的临床目光带入治疗最严重病人的医院时，所有的病人疾病在很大程度上都是一个神话。如果他们做了不同的事情，他们可能本可以更好地治疗这些人。
But they were, they never said, oh, oops, we made a mistake. They just said, oh, it's in remission now. Well, how did it get there? You know, that doesn't make sense even what they knew, what they knew about the diagnosis of the time. So, Rojanthand's conclusion was pretty bleak. He said, you know, these salient characteristics that lead to diagnosis reside in the patient's environments and not in the patients themselves. He had proven this, you know, when he brought the clinical gaze of the intuitive, you know, expert into the hospital where the sickest people were being treated, that all the patient illness was like largely this myth. If they had done something different, they probably could have treated these people better.
他们不必待在那里。并不是所有人都需要他们得到的治疗。所以这些力量在当时正汇聚在精神病学上。有民权活动家说非自愿收治是对自由的侵犯。很多时候，特别是在南方，确实如此。黑人只是被针对。或者当时的西班牙裔，虽然南方没有像非裔美国人那么多的西班牙裔。
They didn't have to be there. They didn't. Not all of them needed the treatment they were kidding. So these forces are all sort of converging on psychiatry at this time. There are civil rights activists who say involuntary commitment is a violation of liberty. And a lot of times, especially in the South it was. Black people were just sort of targeted. Or Hispanic people at that time, you know, there weren't as many Hispanic people in the South that there were African Americans.
但是，同性恋权利活动家说，你说同性恋是一种精神障碍，它并没有伤害任何同意的成年人。公众开始看到像《飞越疯人院》这样的作品，这些作品在某种程度上基于正在发生的事情。他们开始将精神病院视为像拉奇德护士那样的威权药物推销员和执行者。然后你有科学研究人员。研究开始表明评分者间信度非常糟糕。它不起作用。保险公司不想为模糊的反应买单，也不想为那些只想在心理治疗中坐 30 年只为了有个朋友的人买单。
But, you know, gay rights activists say, you know, you said that homosexuality is a mental disorder, you know, and it's not hurting any to consenting adults. The public starts seeing things like one flu over the cuckoo's nest and things that are, you know, sort of based on what's happening. And they just start seeing mental institutions as these are authoritarian drug pushers and enforcers like Nurse Ratchet. And then you have, you know, scientific researchers. Studies start showing that inter-rater reliability is terrible. It's not working. insurance companies are not wanting to pay for vague reactions or the person who wants to sit in psychotherapy for 30 years just to have a friend.
制药行业需要这种同质化的患者群体来进行随机对照试验，因为如果你给所有说“我变得太躁狂或抑郁，以至于我有一点精神分裂症样症状”的人服用精神分裂症药物，而他们没有好转，那并不意味着你的药物无效，因为你把它给了没有精神分裂症的人，但我们根本无法清晰地定义或分诊精神分裂症。所以它到底是什么？如果我们没有人群来给药，我们怎么知道如何研究？
And pharmaceutical industry needed this humongous, this homogeneous, not humongous, sorry, they needed like a consistent group of patient populations for randomized controlled trials, because if you gave a schizophrenia drug to everybody who kind of said, like, well, I got so manic or depressed that I had like a little bit of a schizophrenia-like symptom and then they didn't get better, then that doesn't really mean that your drug doesn't work because you gave it to somebody who doesn't have schizophrenia, but we can't define or triage schizophrenia at all clearly. So like what even is it? And how do we know how to study if we don't have a population to give drugs to?
这是一个很好的问题。我的意思是，这就是你需要诊断标准的原因之一。他们没错。我会说一些关于制药行业的好话。你确实需要一组你正在研究的人群才能进行研究。所以这个职业被视为软弱、主观且在政治上妥协的。舞台已经为这场革命搭建好了。所以当 DSM-3 工作组成立时，罗伯特·斯皮策（Robert Spitzer）被任命为负责人。
Which is a good problem. I mean, that's one of the reasons you need diagnostic criteria. They're not wrong. You know, I'll say something nice about the pharmaceutical industry. You do need a group of people that you're studying in order to do a study. So the profession is viewed a soft, subjective, and politically compromised. And the stage is sort of set for this revolution. So when the DSM3 task force is assembled, Robert Spitzer is put in charge.
这是在 1980 年。这正处于一场保守派推动的时期，说“保守”在这个国家并不意味着太多，因为我们的政党变化太快了，不仅仅是最近。我的意思是，因为互联网等原因，它肯定在加速。但在那个时期，保守主义是在说我们想要问责制。我们不想只是把钱送出去。我们想知道它是否有效。
And this is in 1980. It's sort of during a conservative push for saying conservative doesn't really mean a ton because our political parties change so much in this country, but relatively quickly, not just recently. I mean, it's definitely speeding up because of the Internet and stuff. But conservatism during this time was saying we want accountability. We don't just want money given away. we wanted to know that it works.
你知道，“靠自己努力”的意识形态，但它是关于官僚机构应该介入，证明你确实是最好的员工，我们想要精英管理，我们不想把钱给所有的学校。我们想看看哪所学校做得对，然后把钱给他们，
You know, the bootstraps ideology, but it was about like you have to, bureaucracy should come in here and it should prove that you're actually the best worker and we want a meritocracy and we don't want to give money to all the schools. We want to see which schools is doing it right and give them the money
然后其他学校会跟上，这同样不是坏事。只是当你开始增加官僚机构来测试那些不一定可测试的东西时，你找不到它，因为它不可测试。我记得在布什政府时期，他们需要证明在重组新奥尔良学校系统后，考试成绩有所提高，但考试成绩并没有
and then the other schools will get it together, which again is not a bad thing. It's just that when you start to add bureaucracy to test for things that are not necessarily testable, you can't find it because it's not testable. You know, I remember like during the Bush administration, they needed to prove that after this like restructuring of the new Laurel in school systems the test scores gotten better but the test scores hadn't gotten
提高，当你私有化一切、解雇所有职业教师、引入所有这些“为美国而教”的毕业生并将其全部私有化时。所以他们只是换了一个不同的测试，然后说“好吧，这个测试的分数比另一个高”，但这不科学，因为这是两个不同的测试，而且它是为了得到他们想要的结果而设计的。你知道，还有什么例子？我有一个，但我忘了。这是如果我有更多时间编辑的话，我可能会删掉的内容。但是，是的，所以你有那种保守的能量在发生。
better when you privatized everything and fired all of the career teachers and brought on all these teach for America grads and privatized all of it and so they just gave a different test and they were like well the score on this test is higher than the other one but that's not scientific because it's two different tests and it was designed to get the result they wanted um you know um what's another example of that there's um I had it, and I'm blanking on it. This is the kind of thing that I probably should cut if I had more time in an editor. But, yeah, so you have that sort of conservative energy happening.
哦，我知道是什么了。亚当·柯蒂斯（Adam Curtis）在他的电影中谈到撒切尔和里根上台时，撒切尔说，那些没有看到很多人、没有取得成功、只是让这些人用政府的钱在医院里装病喝酒的医院，我们想让你证明你没有这样做。所以我们要根据床位数量来评判你。所以发生的另一件事是他们只是改变了评估指标。所以很多需要资金、不想被审查、没有时间去争辩说你做得很好或者你本来就可以做得很好的医院，
Oh, I know what it is. Adam Curtis, you know, in one of his movies, he's talking about when Thatcher and Reagan come in, and Thatcher's like hospitals that aren't seeing a bunch of people that aren't being successful, that are just letting these people malinger in wine and drink water on the government dime, We want you to prove you're not doing that. So we're going to judge you based on the number of beds. So another thing that happens is they just change the assessment metric. So a lot of these hospitals that needed funding and didn't want to be scrutinized and didn't have time to, you know, make an argument that you're doing a good job or you can just do a good job.
就像如果你去大多数工作场所，听那个总是在饮水机旁谈论自己有多棒、工作做得有多好的人，通常那个一直在宣传的人并没有在工作，他们是那里最糟糕的人之一。这些系统也是一样。如果有人做得很好，你要求他们跟踪一切、做启发式分析、获取数据并真正证明它，他们要么做他们被雇佣做的事，要么试图防御并用数字来照顾自己。所以英国发生的事情是，他们只是把医院里的椅子重新分类为床位，然后说“是的，每个人都有床位。这就是我们看到的病人数量。”你知道，真实的事情。当你试图将问责制引入这些系统时，有很多这样的事情。所以罗伯特·斯皮策，他是 DSM-3 的主要负责人。
Like if you go to most workplaces and you listen to the person who's always by the water cooler talking about how great they are and what of a great job they do, usually the person that's advertising that all the time isn't working and they're one of the worst people there. Same thing with these systems. Like if somebody's doing a good job and you ask them to like track everything and do heuristics and get data and then really prove it, they can either do what they're hired to do or they can try and be defensive and babysit themselves with numbers. And so what happened in Britain is that they just reclassified like chairs in the hospital to beds and then said, yeah, everybody had a bed. This is how many patients we saw. You know, real thing. Lots of things like that when you try and introduce accountability into these systems. So Robert Spitzer, he's this, you know, the main guy for the DSM3.
他是哥伦比亚大学的教授，通常被描述为一个聪明但有点不同的人。他接受过精神分析训练，但他从未真正符合那种富有同理心的解释性分析师的模式。斯皮策对模糊性感到不舒服。他从未真正喜欢治疗中的那种主观性。所以在 20 世纪 70 年代，他沉迷于分类和数据，并被安排到行政职位，因为他在治疗方面并不擅长。他不像那种温暖或善于建立关系的人。所以，那种拒绝可能让他，或者无法进行治疗的能力，让他想要把它变成一种不同的东西。如果你想要精神分析，那里可能有一点那种东西。
He's a Columbia professor and he's described usually as like a brilliant guy, but kind of different, you know. And he had undergone like psychoanalytic training, but he never really fit the mold of this like empathetic interpretive analyst. Spitzer was more uncomfortable with ambiguity. He never really liked the kind of subjectivity of therapy. And so in the 1970s, he was obsessed with categorization and data and had been sort of put into administrative roles because he wasn't really very good in therapy. He wasn't like warm or relational. And so he, that rejection maybe made him or inability to do therapy made him want to make it, you know, a different thing. If you want to psychoanalysis, there's probably a little bit of that there.
他是哥伦比亚大学的教授，通常被描述为一个才华横溢但有些与众不同的人。他接受过精神分析训练，但从未真正符合那种富有同理心、善于解读的分析师形象。斯皮策对模糊性感到不安，他从不喜欢治疗中的那种主观性。因此，在20世纪70年代，他痴迷于分类和数据，并被安排在行政岗位上，因为他在治疗方面并不擅长。他不够热情，也不善于建立人际关系。这种被拒绝的经历，或者说无法胜任治疗工作的挫败感，可能促使他想要改变这一切。如果你去了解精神分析，或许能从中发现一点这种心理动机。
But he, he's very bright if you ever. anything that he writes, he's smart, but that, you know, again, that doesn't always help you do something good. So the problem in the field was that it was very fractured. Psychoanalysts believed depression was condolous by anger turned inward. You know, biological psychiatrists believed it was a chemical imbalance. Behaviorist wanted it to be learned helplessness that, you know, treat everybody like a lab rat. Behaviorism is growing, exploding in the late 70, you know, in 1975 through 1985, that's where American behaviorism people see it as this thing of like, you don't have to deal with cognition or emotion at all.
但他非常聪明，如果你读过他写的任何东西，他都很聪明，但正如我所说，这并不总能帮你做出好的成果。所以该领域的问题在于它非常分裂。精神分析学家认为抑郁症是愤怒内化导致的；生物精神病学家认为这是化学物质失衡；行为主义者则希望将其归结为习得性无助，就像对待实验室小白鼠一样对待每个人。行为主义在70年代末到80年代中期（1975年至1985年）蓬勃发展，甚至呈爆炸式增长，这就是美国行为主义的现状，人们将其视为一种完全不需要处理认知或情绪的东西。
You can just train people because we're, we just sort of input machines. And so Spitzer's reaction is propose a manual that, you know, ignored the cause entirely. Similar to Beck with CBT, like quit talking about how this stuff got here, talk about what to do because they were angry that psychoanalysts were navel gazing and wasting time, which, you know, valid. So it would solely focus on description.
你只需要训练人们，因为我们就像输入机器一样。因此，斯皮策（Spitzer）的反应是提出了一本完全忽略病因的手册。这类似于贝克（Beck）的认知行为疗法（CBT），即停止讨论这些东西是怎么来的，只谈论该怎么做，因为他们对精神分析学家那种“盯着肚脐看”且浪费时间的做法感到愤怒，这确实有道理。所以它只专注于描述。
It wouldn't matter why the patient was depressed. It only mattered that they had depressed mood, insomnia, weight loss, and fatigue for two weeks. You look at symptoms. And this was this diplomatic, you know, master stroke because it allowed Freudians and biological psychiatrists to use the same codes. But it was also this philosophical retreat from ever trying to figure out, like, what these things were or how we thought the mind worked. We just didn't have to know.
病人为什么抑郁并不重要。重要的是他们是否有抑郁情绪、失眠、体重减轻和疲劳，且持续了两周。你只需要看症状。这是一种外交上的神来之笔，因为它允许弗洛伊德学派和生物精神病学家使用相同的代码。但这也是一种哲学上的退缩，不再试图弄清楚这些东西是什么，或者我们认为大脑是如何运作的。我们只是不需要知道。
We'd have put symptoms together and drew lines around symptoms and called that a diagnosis. But it was just sort of a thing we were making up. So we abandoned the why. there's no reaction to something anymore. Reaction to what and when was the reaction? There's no dynamic force. It's just check these boxes. If these three things, then you have that,
我们把症状放在一起，在症状周围画线，然后称之为诊断。但这只是我们编造出来的东西。所以我们放弃了“为什么”。不再有对某事的反应。对什么反应？什么时候反应？没有动态力量。只是勾选这些方框。如果有这三件事，那你就有那个病。
which paves the way for Psychoform when Prozac comes out as this sort of, you know, mainstream third-gen thing to sweep the world. And so the innovation of the DSM three is checklists. And it was, you know, supposed to be this diagnostic criteria where all the psychiatrists will, agree now because if the patient checks this box for one doctor, they'll check that box for the other
这为百忧解（Prozac）在80年代作为一种主流的“第三代”药物横扫世界铺平了道路。因此，DSM-3的创新就是检查清单。它本应是一种诊断标准，让所有精神科医生达成一致，因为如果病人对一位医生勾选了这个方框，他们也会对另一位医生勾选同样的方框。
doctor, they'll have the same diagnosis. Now we're speaking the same language, right? And again, like, when I look at people like Beck or Spitzer, who I think did a bad thing to the profession, or at least took it in too far of, you know, the other direction, I don't really have any problem with them personally because the problems they're addressing were real. And I also think that those people are kind of this inevitability. It's kind of like Columbus gets all this credit for discovering North America. But like, if you let Columbus like ships sink there's enough ships bumping around in the Caribbean there's so much exploration and interest in that region but it would have been discovered you know the next year like it he just happened to be in the right place at the right time somebody was going to do this stuff it happens to be spitzer and back um that do you know a kind of objectification and surface level let's get the practical let's get to the practicality by scraping the depths out of the thing somebody was going to do that It happens to be them, but, you know, like I don't really have an axe to ground against them because I just think that that they would have been replaced by the next guy. They would have done that.
这样他们就会得出相同的诊断。现在我们说的是同一种语言，对吧？再说一次，当我看到像贝克或斯皮策这样的人时，我认为他们对这个行业做了坏事，或者至少把它带向了另一个极端，但我个人对他们并没有什么意见，因为他们解决的问题是真实的。我也认为这些人是某种必然性。就像哥伦布因发现北美而获得所有赞誉一样，但如果哥伦布的船沉了，加勒比海周围还有那么多船在航行，对该地区的探索和兴趣如此之大，它也会在下一年被发现。他只是恰好在正确的时间出现在正确的地点，总会有人做这些事。恰好是斯皮策和贝克进行了这种客观化和表层化的处理，让我们通过刮掉事物的深度来追求实用性。总会有人这么做，恰好是他们，所以我对他们没什么成见，因为我认为他们迟早会被下一个人取代。他们也会做同样的事。
But Rosenhan, his experiment destroys psychiatry's reliability, and the checklist fixes that. And so this shift to this bureaucratic methodology now feels more scientific, which when I see people who think that they're purely logical, what I see is a fear of interior space and an insecurity, but maybe that's just me. maybe you don't. And so it's just taking responsibility away from the clinician. You know, I did not, I know, I knew that she the manual did. This is just what you have. So it's objective. And now you have this disorder.
但是罗森汉（Rosenhan）的实验摧毁了精神病学的可靠性，而检查清单修复了这一点。因此，这种向官僚化方法的转变现在感觉更科学了。当我看到那些认为自己纯粹是逻辑至上的人时，我看到的是对内心空间的恐惧和不安全感，也许这只是我的看法。也许你并不这么认为。这只是把责任从临床医生身上移开了。你知道，我不知道，我知道手册上是这么说的。这就是你有的病。所以它是客观的。现在你有了这个障碍。
I don't just think that. You don't have to fight with me about it or explain yourself. Just the objective things about you give you the objective thing here. And it doesn't really matter why you did it. If this is going on, you've got it. And so the checklist system is popular. And it sees this like reification of psychiatric. disorders where a diagnosis of like major depression becomes treated as a thing that the person has
我不只是这么想。你不需要为此跟我争论或解释你自己。关于你的客观事实给了你这里客观的诊断。你为什么这样做并不重要。如果这种情况正在发生，你就得了这个病。所以检查清单系统很受欢迎。它看到了精神障碍的这种“具体化”，即重度抑郁症的诊断被视为一个人“拥有”的东西，
instead of a description of what the person is experiencing or a description of a process within the person. So now the diagnoses get tacked onto you. It's not just a way of thinking about how you think, which is that's the change that's important here. We're not thinking about thinking anymore. We're putting people into boxes that they don't always fit into. And so, So this bureaucratic, like, I have people some of the time that are just like, I have to have a diagnosis, I have to know. And I'm like, look, you got a little bit of this. You got a little bit of that. But I got to either check three boxes for this one or five boxes for that one. And you don't meet criteria for any of them. But this is why I think it got there. This is what I think that you're
而不是对一个人正在经历什么的描述，也不是对一个人内部过程的描述。所以现在诊断被贴在你身上。这不仅仅是一种思考你如何思考的方式，这才是这里重要的变化。我们不再思考“思考”本身了。我们把人们放进他们并不总是适合的盒子里。所以，这种官僚主义……有时人们会说：“我必须有一个诊断，我必须知道。”我说：“看，你有一点这个，有一点那个。但我必须为这个勾选三个方框，或者为那个勾选五个方框。你哪一个都不符合标准。但这正是我认为问题所在的原因。这就是我认为你正在做的事情。”
doing. This is what I think you're compensating for. This is how I would treat that. And you came here to get better, right? So this is how you could be treated. But you're landing in this vague or more general diagnosis just because you kind of have elements of these this dopamine disorder or asd or ADHD but you don't totally meet criteria if you want a diagnosis based on the book if you want to all refer you to psych testing and i've had two or three that go and they pay a lot of money and they do these all-day psychiatric tests and i flip to the end of those reports when i get them and they say this person doesn't meet criteria for any of these things but they show um you know they show um symptoms of these but just not enough to meet diagnosis and it's like okay
“这就是我认为你在补偿的东西。这就是我会如何治疗它。你来这里是为了好起来，对吧？所以这就是你可以被治疗的方式。但你最终得到了这个模糊或更通用的诊断，仅仅是因为你有这些多巴胺障碍、自闭症谱系障碍（ASD）或多动症（ADHD）的元素，但你并不完全符合标准。如果你想要基于书本的诊断，我会把你转介给心理测试。”我有两三个病人去做了，他们花了很多钱，做了全天的精神科测试。当我拿到报告翻到最后时，上面写着：“此人并不符合这些疾病的任何标准，但他们表现出……你知道，他们表现出……这些症状，但不足以达到诊断标准。”就像是，好吧。
Yep. That was an expensive way to get back there. If you want to just wait two or three more years, the diagnosis will be different anyway. And then when it's different, you can just go ahead and get the newest one. So there's this feeling that happens at this point, which we still have, that if we have this scientific answer that explains why we are the way we are, all of a sudden we won't feel the way we feel. And I think that's a problem, too, because that isn't true. You know, the diagnosis doesn't help you.
是的。那是一种回到原点的昂贵方式。如果你想再等两三年，诊断结果反正也会变。当它变了的时候，你可以直接去拿最新的那个。所以在这个时候会产生一种感觉，我们现在仍然有这种感觉：如果我们有了能解释我们为什么会变成这样的科学答案，突然之间我们就不会有现在的感受了。我认为这也是一个问题，因为那不是真的。你知道，诊断并不能帮助你。
It guides the treatment that helps you. And a lot of people view diagnosis as treatment. Like a lot of people will go get diagnosed with autism now and then be like, oh, this explains so much I have autism and then leave and never pursue treatment or changing anything. It's like, well, why did you need this got random guy to tell you that you had this thing that they made up, basically? You know, like we could make up lots of different ways to do this. This is the one we have right now. and I'm not saying that they shouldn't do that.
它指导的是能帮助你的治疗。很多人把诊断视为治疗。就像现在很多人去诊断出自闭症，然后说：“哦，这解释了很多，我有自闭症。”然后离开，从不寻求治疗或改变任何事情。就像是，好吧，你为什么需要这个随机的人告诉你，你得了这个他们基本上编出来的东西？你知道，我们可以编造很多不同的方法来做这件事。这是我们现在拥有的方法。我并不是说他们不应该这样做。
I'm just saying that that's something that a lot of people do. And it seems strange to me because the whole point of diagnosis is to guide treatment to change the way you feel. And if you're just getting the diagnosis to sort of justify the way you feel, why do we need psychology at all at that point? You know, it's just like a card catalog or something in a library. It's a Dewey Decimal system for people. It's not like a tool to affect the way that we live and feel. feel and relate, which is what I think it is, but some patients don't because they want a diagnosis and then they want it in one session and then they want to leave.
我只是说这是很多人会做的事情。这对我来说很奇怪，因为诊断的全部意义在于指导治疗，以改变你的感受。如果你只是为了证明你的感受而获得诊断，那我们为什么还需要心理学呢？这就像图书馆里的卡片目录一样。它是人类的杜威十进制分类法。它不是一种影响我们生活、感受和联系的工具，而我认为这才是它的意义所在。但有些病人不这么认为，因为他们想要一个诊断，然后他们想在一次会谈中就得到它，然后他们就想离开。
So Spitzer even says later the pharmaceutical companies were too delighted with the DSM3 and the checklist created this perfect target for drug development. He regrets that. And then he sort of sees, you know, things like the panic disorder and things he sort of thought should be treated, just drugged. And then the hospital leaves the walls of the hospital. have the DSM-3 because you don't have to go to the hospital anymore. You know, all of a sudden the hospital can come to you.
所以斯皮策后来甚至说，制药公司对DSM-3和检查清单太满意了，这为药物开发创造了完美的目标。他对此感到后悔。然后他看到，你知道，像恐慌症之类他认为应该治疗的东西，只是被药物处理了。然后医院离开了医院的围墙，因为有了DSM-3，你就不必再去医院了。你知道，突然之间，医院可以来到你身边。
And, you know, one of the issues that I have and a lot of people have with people that are over-medicated is that you're taking a behavior that you really could change if you wanted to, and then you're adding in a drug that takes a chunk of your personality and these other things so that you don't have to change it. And I think you should treat trauma and get to, you know, as high of a functional state as you can and then medicate the things that are sort of endogenous the way rain works and are not going to go away and that you should definitely weigh the pros and cons of medication. That is a little bit more measured of an approach than we've had for the last 20 years.
而且，你知道，我和很多人对那些过度用药的人有一个问题，那就是你正在采取一种如果你愿意其实可以改变的行为，然后你加入了一种药物，它带走了你性格的一部分和其他东西，这样你就不必改变它了。我认为你应该治疗创伤，并达到你所能达到的最高功能状态，然后对那些内源性的、像雨水运作方式一样不会消失的东西进行药物治疗，而且你绝对应该权衡药物的利弊。这比我们过去20年采取的方法要审慎一些。
But, you know, I'm not the king of the world. So who cares what I think? But that implicit in that DSM3 is this revolution where we don't define the phenotype, the symptom, reliably, then the genotype, the gene, and the biological mechanism, it would never be found. So it's seen as like if we put all these symptoms and categories, then we'll find the cause, and it won't be what the psychoanalyst think. It'll be some brilliant new science thing. So this is just this pragmatic placeholder that we're doing until neuroscience can explain to me why everybody's depressed. And this assumption was never fully articulated, but there's this
但是，你知道，我不是世界之王。所以谁在乎我怎么想呢？但DSM-3中隐含着一场革命，如果我们不能可靠地定义表型（症状），那么基因型（基因）和生物学机制就永远不会被发现。所以它被视为：如果我们把所有这些症状和类别放在一起，那么我们就会找到原因，而且它不会是精神分析学家所想的那样。它将是一些辉煌的新科学发现。所以这只是一个务实的占位符，直到神经科学能向我解释为什么每个人都抑郁。这种假设从未被完全阐明，但有一种
pervading idea that psychiatry would assume have its own germ theory. of the specific cause of the thing. Just as medicine discovered pathogens or specific diseases, psychiatry would discover specific brain lesions or neurotransmitter imbalances or genetic markers or something that they can point to that it's explaining behavior that makes it a little bit more biological than just symptoms together. But that never happened, you know? And they were expecting it to happen.
普遍的想法是，精神病学很快就会有自己的“细菌理论”，即特定疾病的特定原因。正如医学发现了病原体或特定疾病一样，精神病学也会发现特定的脑损伤、神经递质失衡、遗传标记或其他他们可以指出的东西，这些东西解释了行为，使其比仅仅把症状堆在一起更具生物学意义。但这从未发生，你知道吗？他们一直在期待它发生。
Like in the DSM-4, I think a lot of people who were initially conceiving of it, why it didn't change anything people thought would change and it didn't go in a direction people liked was that when they announced publication the initial idea was like we're going to put we're going to like the human genome project by that point will be really far along so we'll have all that data and that'll probably give us some information but then it about like the difference the connection between biological biology and psychology but then it didn't like the human genome project wasn't super useful for understanding these things. And so then they had to publish something,
比如在DSM-4中，我认为很多最初构思它的人，为什么它没有改变人们认为会改变的东西，也没有朝着人们喜欢的方向发展，是因为当他们宣布出版时，最初的想法是：“我们要把……到那时人类基因组计划将非常深入，所以我们将拥有所有这些数据，这可能会给我们提供一些信息。”但后来关于生物学和心理学之间的联系，它并没有……人类基因组计划对于理解这些东西并不是特别有用。所以他们不得不出版一些东西，
and the APA certainly makes a lot of money publishing the DSM. So they also have other incentives to do that. And so you get, you know, this, like Alan Francis, has this kind of reaction to the DSM3. And he says that it's diagnostic inflation, that the checklists are so easy to use and they're so divorced from any context that the boundaries of mental illness are expanding too rapidly in normal human suffering,
而且美国精神医学学会（APA）出版DSM确实赚了很多钱。所以他们也有其他动机这样做。所以你会得到，你知道，像艾伦·弗朗西斯（Alan Francis）对DSM-3的这种反应。他说这是“诊断通胀”，检查清单太容易使用了，而且它们与任何背景脱节，以至于精神疾病的边界正在过度扩张到正常的人类痛苦中，
you know, grief or shyness or boisterousness, or the individual psychology of the person, that somebody who is a hypochondriac or that somebody who views themselves as a victim who needs help and they can't learn to feel better on their own. They need to figure out what's wrong with them through some external source. They're going to be more likely to collect all these diagnosis, which still is true. You know, Francis is right. And so he says the DSM-4 is this conservative, reaction and his goal was to like hold the line against this proliferation of new disorders and say we don't need you know all of this new stuff that's just going to every time anyone feels bad now they have a diagnosis
你知道，悲伤、害羞、喧闹，或者个人的心理，那些疑病症患者，或者那些认为自己是需要帮助的受害者且无法学会自我感觉更好的人。他们需要通过某种外部来源找出自己出了什么问题。他们会更有可能收集所有这些诊断，这仍然是真的。你知道，弗朗西斯是对的。所以他说DSM-4是一次保守的反应，他的目标是阻止这种新疾病的激增，并说我们不需要所有这些新东西，这只会导致现在每个人只要感觉不好就有一个诊断。
which is an argument you know people still make and so when you move to the DSM 5 there's this new idea of like spectrums like people have been talking about autism spectrum and they wanted to have this paradigm shift but the problem is like like the committees that make these things are enormous and their subcommittees. I mean, it's like a Congress within a Congress and a Senate, and there's psychiatrists and clinical psychologists and social workers. And the social workers get up and the social workers say, like, well, this is the person in the environment theory and you're being too pathologizing. And of course, nobody listens to them. Well, I mean, one of the DSM-5 people, the lady who did the grief,
这是一个人们仍然在争论的观点。所以当你转向DSM-5时，出现了一个关于“谱系”的新想法，就像人们一直在谈论自闭症谱系一样，他们想要进行这种范式转移。但问题是，制定这些东西的委员会非常庞大，还有下属委员会。我的意思是，这就像国会里的国会和参议院，有精神科医生、临床心理学家和社会工作者。社会工作者站起来说：“好吧，这是‘人在环境中’的理论，你们太病理化了。”当然，没人听他们的。好吧，我的意思是，DSM-5的成员之一，那个负责悲伤诊断的女士，
the new grief diagnosis, she was a PhD social work teacher who found all this sort of cultural and sociological information and then turned it into a diagnosis that they did accept. So I'm not trying to downplay the role of social workers. I just mean that if the biomedical model has to choose between the lived experience of a social worker and the profit motive in health care, who do you think they're going to pick? And like the, so the people, short version of that is that not everybody on these things agrees. So a lot of times there's like the main people, the chair and the board, like have this sort of
那个新的悲伤诊断，她是一位拥有博士学位的社会工作教师，她发现了所有这些文化和社会学信息，然后将其转化为他们确实接受的诊断。所以我不是要淡化社会工作者的作用。我只是说，如果生物医学模型必须在社会工作者的生活经验和医疗保健的利润动机之间做出选择，你认为他们会选谁？简短的版本是，这些人并不都同意。所以很多时候，主要负责人，主席和董事会，对它将成为什么样子有一种宏大的愿景，就像他们对DSM-3所做的那样。DSM-3可能是唯一一个从头到尾都在讲述同一个故事，或者完成了它打算讲述的故事的版本。第四版和第五版没有做到这一点，这就是我对它们有很多意见的原因。他们开始把所有这些谱系诊断和东西放进委员会。然后，我们对具体情况了解不多。我的意思是，人们在谈论。有些人说了一些话。
grand vision for what it's going to be, just like they did with, I mean, the DSM3 may be. the only one that, like, from beginning to end was telling the same story or it finished the story that it set out to tell. The four and the five didn't do that, which is a lot of my issue with them. They started to get all these spectrum diagnosis and things into committee. And then, and we don't know a ton about exactly. I mean, people talk. There's some people that said some stuff.
但是，有保密协议（NDA）阻止任何人做任何事，因为你不希望出现这种政治反弹，有人跳出来说：“某某人不想让跨性别者有这个那个，或者某某人不想让什么什么。”然后突然之间，你让公众参与进来了，对这个本应是某种东西的东西施加了外部压力。所以我认为保密协议在他们的意图上并不是非常邪恶的，它们可能很糟糕，它们在效果上可能有一点邪恶，但很多这些事情我们都不知道。如果有人在房间外说了什么，然后他们又在委员会里，那么他们可能在委员会里也说了同样的话，所以你可以知道人们说了什么，但这并不是一个公开的
But, like, there's NDAs that stop anybody from doing whatever because you don't want there to be this political backlash where somebody comes out and they're like, so and so don't want trans people to have bobby blah or so-and-so doesn't want whatever and then and then all of a sudden you're involving the public with external pressure on this thing that's supposed to be whatever so I don't think the NDAs are terribly nefarious in their intention they may be terrible they may be a little bit nefarious in their effect but a lot of these things we don't know like if somebody's saying something outside of the room and then they're on the committee then they probably said the same thing in the committee so you can kind of know what people say but this is not a public
过程。很少有部分是公开的。即使对参与其中的人来说，我的意思是，有这些审查证据的下属听证会，然后更大的委员会听取每个人的意见，然后他们做出决定。最终，这取决于主席这个小团体来梳理整个过程并出版另一本书。所以这不仅仅是一个人坐下来，所有精神病学界投票通过。你知道，斯皮策是主席。这些都是巨大的过程。到了DSM-5的时候，它已经变得极其庞大，是……最复杂的项目之一。我想知道人们是否会得到报酬，如果你知道的话请发邮件告诉我，如果我想成为DSM-6的作者，虽然我不想，但如果我飞过去坐在那里四个月，你做那个能赚很多钱吗？怎么
process. Very little of it is public. And even to the people in it, I mean, there's these sub-hearings that review evidence and then the bigger board listens to everybody and then they make a decision. And then ultimately, it's up to this kind of small group in the chair to sort it through the entire process and publish another book. So this isn't just like one guy sitting down and all of psychiatry votes for it. You know, Spitzers, the chair. Like these are huge processes. And by the time we got at the DSM-5, it was ginormous, like one of the most complicated, you know, projects. And I wonder if does people get paid email me if you know that like if i want to be like a dsm 6 writer which i don't but like if i flew up there and sat there for like four months do you make a lot of money doing that how
他们付给这些人多少钱？还是他们只是为了某种名声而做？我想知道这一点，但我不知道。总之，这些愿望是把所有东西都放在一个谱系上，所以你不是一直回到过程，但你是在说：“嘿，这不仅仅是一个检查清单，它有点像……”批评者讨厌这一点，他们说：“自闭症谱系障碍，这是什么？你把一个无法说话或完全无法运作的人，一直到那种有一个过度保护母亲的宅男，放在同一个谱系里。你说这是同一回事。”你知道，他们不喜欢那样。因为那是一个巨大的范围。但如果你要转向谱系模式，
much do they pay these guys or are they just doing it for like the street cred i would like to know that and i don't um anyway so the these aspirations was that you put everything on a spectrum so you're not going all the way back to processes but you are saying like hey it's not just a checklist it's kind of like this is whatever and the critics hate that and they're like autism spectrum disorder what is this? Like you're putting a spectrum between a person who can't talk or function at all, all the way down to somebody who had like a shut in mail with an overprotective mom. And you're saying like, that's the same thing. You know, they're like, they don't like that. Because that's, I mean, it is a huge range. But if you're going to move to a spectrum thing,
这可能是一种更好的做法，可能不是完美的，但比我们在第四版中做的要好。那么你需要致力于此并付诸实践。但当他们进入委员会时，他们会争吵。愿景从来没有真正充实或完成。所以你基本上把所有这些东西都塞进了书的末尾。就像那些治疗修订版过去很小，比如在早期的版本中，他们会说……或者不是治疗修订版。那些是……治疗修订版就像是微软Windows 3，
which is probably a better way to do it, probably not a perfect way, but a better way than what we were doing in the fore. Then you need to kind of commit to that and do it. But when they get into committee, they fight. And the vision is not ever really fleshed out or finished. And so you get all this stuff crammed into the end of the book, basically. Like those treatment revisions used to be tiny, like in the early ones where they were like, or not treatment revisions. Those are the individual. Those are the treatment revisions are like where they're like, this is Microsoft Windows 3,
但还不是微软Windows 95。这是微软NT。我们在做XP，但我们还没做完。它是4.5或者5.2，它是中间版本。我不是那个意思，我想说的是附录。附录过去很小，它们就像：“这里有一些有用的信息，比如鉴别诊断树，然后嘿，这里有一些我们讨论过的事情，看起来很重要，但我们还没有完全……这是为未来考虑而提出的。”所以如果你想研究它，或者如果你想思考它，并可能发表一些东西，
but it's not Microsoft Windows 95 yet. This is Microsoft, you know, NT. It's we're working on XP, but we're not. done with it it's the 4.5 or the you know 5.2 it's like the in-between version that's not what I mean what I'm trying to talk about is appendixists the appendixists used to be tiny they were like here's some useful information like differential diagnostic trees and then hey here's some stuff we talked about that seems important but we haven't quite this is proposed for future consideration so you know if you want to research it or if you want to think about it and may publish something like
为下一个版本权衡一下。它们过去非常小，现在因为他们无法就如何写书达成一致，而且这些都是巨大的“委员会绘画”作品，所以附录已经膨胀了。他们所做的是，他们采取了整个谱系的东西，然后说：“嘿，我们认为这是对的，但我们还不会让它成为现实。”所以我们只是把所有这些都塞在最后，所以它不是书的一部分，但它仍然在说：“嘿，我们认为这是真的。”但谱系的东西与诊断检查清单完全不一致，而检查清单仍然是这本书运作的方式。所以，你们在做什么？你知道，这是另一件有趣的事情，就像我认为你可以让世界上所有的精神科医生坐下来，尝试制作一本他们喜欢的DSM。
way in on that for the next version they used to be teeny tiny and now that they can't agree on like how to write the book and there's these giant you know paint by committee things then the appendixes have just ballooned and what they do is they take the whole spectrum thing and they say like hey we think this is right but we're not going to make it real yet um so we're just going to stick all of that in the end so it's not part of the book but it's still saying like hey we think this is real but the spectrum stuff is completely at odds with the diagnostic checklist which is still how the book functions so like what are you doing you know that's that's another thing that's interesting is like I think you could have every psychiatrist in the world sit down and try and make a DSM that they like.
那是他们最喜欢的版本。你永远不会得到像这样的东西。因为科学是通过辩论完成的，但并非所有的辩论都是科学。你看看这些书，就像DSM-5中的核心单元是反应和过程。但分类检查清单是这种离散的障碍类别。然后是你在最后可以关注的名义上的谱系，这是一个巨大的伞形类别。但同时，是的，想想所有那些相互矛盾的东西，
That's their favorite version. And you would never end up with anything like this. Because, you know, science is done through debate, but not all debate is science. And you look at these books and it's like the core unit of, you know, is a reaction and a process in the DSM-5. But the categorical checklist is this discrete disorder category. And then the nominal spectrum that you can kind of pay attention at the end. end is this huge umbrella category. But then also, yeah, just think about all those things all the time that sort of contradict
它们基于三个不同的时代和四五个不同的概念，像“达格伍德三明治”一样堆在一起，根本没有任何意义。所以就像是，伙计，我该怎么办？你永远、永远不会从一个人的头脑中得到这本书。它基本上是一项关于为什么冲突解决的研究。它是一份冲突解决的文件，而不是一份诊断和统计手册。如果你从头读到尾并试图按照它说的做，它并没有太大的意义，
and are based on like three different eras and four or five different conceptualizations dagwood sandwich together that don't really make any sense. So it's like, what am I supposed to do, man? Like you would never, ever get this book out of one mind. And it basically is like a study in why conflict resolution. It's like a document of conflict resolution instead of a deal. of a diagnostic and statistical manual. It doesn't make a ton of sense if you read it cover to cover and try and do what it says
因为它并没有真正告诉你如何思考这些东西，或者如何……这些东西的全部意义在于说：“这就是美国精神医学学会思考和构思它的方式。”也许这里有一些选项和想法，但这就是我们的想法，我们不再有一个统一的想法，我们只是在出版那个。很奇怪。所以该结论的科学依据相当稳健。有这些纵向和聚类分析。他们查看的数据表明，存在这种区别，你知道，对于自闭症
because it's not really telling you how to think about this stuff or how, and the whole point of these are to say this is how the APA thinks and conceives of it. Maybe here's some options and ideas, but like this is our idea and we don't have one anymore and we're just publishing that. Weird. So the scientific rationale for that conclusion is pretty robust. There's these logitudinal and cluster analysis. the data that they look at and it suggests that there's this distinction you know between uh for autism
特别是，因为阿斯伯格综合征对他们来说一直是个问题，自闭症和阿斯伯格综合征之间存在这种区别，但它是人为的，因为你在哪里划线？你可以在任何地方划线。所以让我们把它变成一个谱系，诊断本身就是那条线。所以临床医生真的觉得这会发生，在不同的地点，他们应用这些标签，并且在任何地方都是一致的。如果你把它变成一条线，把人放在上面就容易多了，不会排除任何需要它的人，也不会加入任何不需要它的人，这正是诊断的全部意义所在：把那些没有病的人排除在外，但你无法就它是什么或它来自哪里达成一致，然后把那些确实有病的人留在里面。
especially because asperger's was always problematic to them there's this distinction between autism and asperger's but it's kind of artificial because where do you draw the line you could draw it anywhere so let's just make it a spectrum where it just the diagnosis is the line and so clinicians really feel like that's going to happen and at different sites they were applying those labels and consistently anywhere if you make it a line it's a lot easier to put people on it and not exclude anybody who needs it and not at anybody who doesn't, which is the whole point of a diagnosis is to keep the ones that don't have something, but you can't agree on what it is or where it comes from out and then keep the people that all do have it, keep them in it.
所以，ASD谱系的这种操作化，当他们说“但我们如何基于该假设进行操作？”时，引发了所有这些担忧。就像这些人说：“我们认为这就是神经发育大脑的工作方式，这就是基于科学的意识和认知的工作方式。”然后那些说“我们必须用这些信息做点什么”的人，如何基于该假设进行操作？他们会生气。
So how that operationalism of the ASD spectrum, it raises all these concerns when they're saying, like, but how do we operate based on that assumption? Like these people say, this is how the neurodevelopmental brain works, we think, and this is how conscious and cognition works based on the science. And then the people who are saying, we have to do something with that information. How do we operate based on that assumption? Get mad.
他们说：“研究表明该标准的特异性更好。”但敏感性，你知道，挑选和发现它的能力较差。这意味着有一大部分个体，特别是那些认知功能较高或之前被诊断出其他疾病的人，他们将在这种谱系规则下失去获得服务的机会，因为谱系让更多人被包括在内，但也让那些与你划定的那条线不相似的人
And they say, you know, research indicates the specificity of this criteria is better. But the sensitivity, you know, how well it is to pick it up and find it is less. And this means that there's a significant, you know, subset of individuals, particularly those with higher cognitive functioning or those that were previously diagnosed, you know, with other things, they're going to lose access to services under this spectrum role because the spectrum is making more people included, but it's also making people that are not similar to that line that you're drawing
被踢出去了。所以如果你有一个诊断，它只是一个检查清单。你要么符合标准，要么不符合。如果你有一条线，你必须有很多症状，你必须有很多症状，你必须与那条线相似。但如果你有一些症状，而诊断并不真正符合那条线，或者
be kicked out. So like if you have a diagnosis, it's just a checklist. You either fit the criteria you don't. If you have a line, you have to have a whole lot of symptoms that you like, that you have to have a whole lot of symptoms, that you are similar to. But if you had some of those symptoms than a diagnosis that aren't really on that line or the
诊断消失了，那么你就有一些患有某种疾病但现在没有被诊断出来的人，他们无法再接受医疗护理。这种情况在很多疾病中都会发生。我不会逐一列举所有的变化。我的意思是，你可以去查一下。那不是重点。你知道，精神分裂症类别，对我来说从来没有太大的意义。我的意思是，我不认为美国有紧张型精神分裂症患者。
diagnosis goes away, then you have people who have something that isn't diagnosed now that no longer can receive medical care. And that happens with a bunch of these. And I'm not going to go through every change. I mean, you can look that up. That's not the point. You know, the schizophrenia categories, which never really made a ton of sense to me. I mean, I don't think there's been a catatonic schizophrenia patient.
已经100年了。那些诊断，就像，消失了，它们变得更像是精神病障碍。而且，你知道，艾伦·弗朗西斯说，通过将精神分裂症变成“减弱的精神病”，在很多情况下，这将导致对那些根本没病、古怪或偏执的人进行大规模的医疗化。他们有权那样做。而且预测转化为完全精神病的假阳性率。就像这个人患有精神分裂症，你想知道那个人是否会……
in America for, you know, 100 years. Those diagnoses, like, go away and they become more just psychosis disorders. And, you know, and Alan Francis says that by turning schizophrenia into attenuated psychosis, in a lot of instances, this would lead to this massive medicalization of weird or eccentric people who there's nothing wrong with. They have the right to do that. and the false positive rate for predicting conversion to full psychosis. Like this person has schizophrenia, you want to know that that person's going to get,
基本上你想对精神分裂症做的是，因为它发病年龄长。有一个前驱期。前驱期就是你做的事情有点奇怪，但你仍然与现实相连。所以你四处游荡，突然之间你有了这种妄想，你会说：“嘿，那有点奇怪。我不知道为什么我会这么想，但我知道它是真的。”但你相对功能良好。
basically what you want to do with schizophrenia because it's a long age of onset. There's a progenital period. And the progenital period is where like you're doing stuff that's like kind of odd, but you're still connected to reality. So like you wander around and all of a sudden you have this delusion and you're like, hey, that's kind of weird. I don't know why I think that, but I know it's true. But you're relatively well functioning.
你比那些完全失去现实感、发生精神分裂的人有更多这样的时刻。你知道，如果不治疗，你是否可能导致脑损伤或在行为上做一些让你搞砸的事情？所以这种障碍的全部意义在于：我们如何抓住那些处于前驱期、相信一些奇怪的事情或出现以前没有的奇怪、异常信念的人？我们如何抓住这一点来预测精神病的发生？
You have a little bit more of those than you lose total. with reality, have a psychotic split. You know, if it's not treated, do you have maybe the possibility of brain damage or doing behaviorally a thing that messes you up? So the whole point of the disorder is like, how do we catch these people who are in the prodromal phase who believe some odd stuff or having strange, aberrant beliefs pop up that weren't there before? How do we catch that to predict the onset of psychosis?
就像，这就是你在一个有效的精神分裂症诊断中想要的。但他们做不到，因为如果你说：“嘿，每个表现得好像处于精神分裂症前驱期并相信一些奇怪古怪事情的人，都给他们贴上精神病障碍的标签。”现在你挑选出了那些可能永远不会发生完全精神分裂的人。所以有一种争论。如果你们在乎的话，我的回答是，精神病是你可能面临更大风险的东西，有点像癌症。就像你可以有癌症基因，或者你可以抽烟得癌症，或者你可以有导致或不导致你得癌症的饮食。
Like, that's what you want in a schizophrenia diagnosis that works. But they can't do that because if you say, hey, everybody who's acting like they have the prodromal phase of schizophrenia and believe some weird eccentric stuff, go ahead and flag them with a psychosis disorder. Now you're picking up people who may never have a full psychotic split. And so there's kind of this fight. I would say my answer to that if you care is that like psychosis is something that you can be more at risk for, kind of like cancer. Like you can have the genes for cancer or you can smoke with cigarettes to get cancer or you can have the diet that does or doesn't give you cancer.
但所有这些风险因素加起来，使得这件事更有可能发生。所以有些人，很多人，无论如何都会得精神分裂症。他们做什么并不重要。这只是，你知道，我们可以追溯到的最远的地方，奶奶做了一些奇怪的事。爸爸有双相情感障碍。这个人有多巴胺障碍。多巴胺障碍在家族中遗传很多。我有很多这种病的基因，当我18岁上大学时，这件事就会发生。
But like all of those risk factors add up to the thing being more likely. And so there's some people, a lot of people, that are going to get schizophrenia anyway. It doesn't matter what they do. It's just, you know, as far back as we can go, grandma did something weird. Dad had bipolar disorder. This person had dopamine disorder. Dopamine disorders run in families a lot. I've got so much of the genes for the thing that when I hit 18, I'm going to have this thing happen in college.
其他人可能在他们会发生某种精神崩溃的地方，但他们服用LSD和吸食大麻，这使得结果变得更糟。崩溃比本来会发生的更严重。其他人可能永远不会得病，除非环境没有保护他们。他们有一点基因，而这些东西加在一起。但DSM不是，它不是，你知道，以一种概率或累积的方式来做。它试图转向一个谱系。我所描述的很有道理，但那不是一个谱系，对吧？我比检查清单更喜欢谱系，但谱系仍然无法做到我所描述的这件事，即：你如何抓住人们并基本上把可能性和风险因素加起来，然后说所有这些事情都导致了这件事作为一种致病因素。他们说：“好吧，那信息量太大了。我们可能没有全部信息。”你知道，我们不知道他们使用或将使用多少药物。我们不知道他们的遗传史。而且，你知道，你怎么筛选这个？我真的不知道，除了和病人坐在一起几个小时，和他们交谈，
Other people maybe have it where they're going to have a sort of psychotic break, but they take LSD and they do marijuana, and that makes the outcome way worse. The break is worse than it would have been. Other people may never have gotten it except the inviote. environment doesn't protect them. They have a little bit of the genes and those things compound. But the DSM was not, it wasn't, you know, doing it in a probability or a cumulative way. It was trying to move to a spectrum. And what I'm describing makes sense, but that isn't a spectrum, right? I like the spectrum more than the checklist, but the spectrum still can't do this thing that I'm describing, which is, you know, how do you catch people and add up basically
并获得所有这些信息，这就是我所做的。然后说：“好吧，你知道，这就是我的想法。这就是我认为的创伤，是可以治疗的。这就是多巴胺障碍，你知道，治疗创伤会减轻它的一些症状。但我认为你可能总是需要药物来治疗强迫症或精神分裂症，因为如果你不治疗创伤，你可能需要的药物会更少。”我可以和病人进行那种对话，而像这样的一本书从根本上无法告诉人们如何用谱系概念进行那种对话。我希望这说得通。
likelihoods and risk factors and then say all of these things contributed to this happening as a causative thing. They're like, well, that's too much information. We may not have all of it. You know, we don't know how many drugs they use or will use. And we don't know their genetic history. And, you know, how do you screen for that? And I don't really know other than sit with a patient for a couple hours and talk to them
所以DSM-4是人格障碍的模型，它有10个不同的类别，比如自恋型、边缘型、回避型。到第五版编写时，这在科学上被认为是破产的，因为有太多的共病，你会说：“好吧，边缘型现在表现得像表演型。所以我给她那个，或者给他那个。”但后来有太多的重叠。所以DSM-3本应消除的同样的事情，你知道，你又在诊断上产生分歧了。所以人格障碍进行了全面改革。
and get all that information, which is what I do. And then say, okay, you know, this is kind of what I think. This is what I think the trauma is, which can be treated. And this is what the dopamine disorder is, which, you know, treating the trauma is going to bring down the symptoms of that some. but I think you're always probably going to need medication for OCD or schizophrenia because you may be on less than if you didn't treat the trauma. I can have that conversation with a patient, whereas a book like this fundamentally can't tell people how to have that conversation with a spectrum conceptualization. I hope that that makes sense.
里面有很多东西，他们基本上说标准A，即：人格功能水平在0到4的损害等级上是多少？你知道，如果它没有造成问题，我们就不会把它病理化。然后标准B是病理人格障碍特征。你有这些特征中的任何一个吗？让我们把它们放在五个领域中，比如我们正在寻找的不同类型的人格特征：负面情绪、疏离、对抗、去抑制、精神病性。我不知道这是不是更好的做法。它可能只是更复杂的一种。我认为你最终可能会得到同样的共病问题。
So the DSM 4 was this model of personality disorders, which is like 10 distinct categories like narcissistic borderline avoidant. And that is kind of recognized by the time the fives being written is like scientifically bankrupt because there's like all this comorbidity where you're like, well, the borderline is acting histrionic right now. So I'm going to give her that one or I'm going to give him that one. And but then there's all this overlap. So the same thing that the DSM3 was supposed to get rid of, you know, you're disagreeing on diagnoses again. So there's this overhaul for personality disorders.
我的意思是，另一件事是测试和实施疲劳。你可以让这些系统变得极其复杂。但现实是，你让它们越复杂，人们做对的可能性就越小。因为急诊医生工作过度，治疗师只是想做他们想做的事情。当你告诉他们，他们必须花几个小时做成堆的其他事情时，只是更少的人会去做。然后诊断反正也没有意义。所以这个系统还有另一个问题。所以发生的大事是，你知道，美国国家心理健康研究所（NIMH），联邦政府，
There's a bunch of stuff in it where they say basically Criterion A, which is like, what's the level of personality functioning on a zero to four rating of impairment? You know, if it's not causing a problem, we're not going to pathologize it. And then Criterion B is like pathological personality disorder traits. Do you have any of these traits? And let's put them in five domains of like different types of different types of personality traits we're looking for negative effectivity, detachment, antagonism, disinhibition, psychoticism. I don't know that that's a better way to do it. It may just be a more complicated one. I think you're probably going to end up with the same comorbidity things.
在托马斯·因塞尔（Thomas Insull）担任所长的情况下，但无论如何这可能都会发生，就像是：“我不再使用DSM了，因为DSM从来没有真正可靠或有效。如果我们用它来研究事物，我们就无法成功，因为我们聚集在一起的症状并不能真正让研究变得更好。”
I mean, one of the other things is like testing and implementation fatigue. Like you can make these systems incredibly complicated. But the reality is that the more complicated you make them, the less people will do it right. Because an ER doctor is overworked and a therapist is just trying to get to the thing that they want to do. When you tell them that they have to do like reams and reams of other stuff for hours, just less people do it. and then the diagnosis don't mean anything anyway. So there's another, you know, problem with this system. So the big thing that happens is, you know, the NIMH, the federal governments,
我的意思是，另一个问题是测试和实施带来的疲劳感。你可以把这些系统设计得极其复杂，但现实是，系统越复杂，人们就越难正确使用。因为急诊室医生工作过度，而治疗师只想专注于他们想做的事情。当你告诉他们必须额外花费数小时去处理海量琐事时，只会导致更少的人去执行，最终诊断结果也就失去了意义。所以，这个系统还存在另一个问题。因此，发生了一件大事，那就是美国国家心理健康研究所（NIMH），即联邦政府机构，
the National Institute of Mental Health, with Thomas Insull as director, but it probably would have happened anyway is like, I'm not going to use the DSM anymore because the DSM has never really been reliable or valid. And we can't succeed if we're using this to study things because the symptoms that we're clustering together aren't really going to make research any better.
在托马斯·因塞尔担任所长期间，或者说即便没有他，这件事也迟早会发生，那就是他们宣布不再使用《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》（DSM），因为DSM从未真正具备可靠性或有效性。如果我们用它来研究问题，就无法取得成功，因为我们归纳在一起的症状并不能真正改善研究质量。
It's not going to figure out if drugs work. It's not going to figure out if this type of therapy treats this type of thing because you're just calling it PTSD, but really PTSD is like four things. So which one of the four was it? Just looking at PTSD diagnosis doesn't mean anything. And I agree with that critique. I don't really agree with the NIMH
它无法判断药物是否有效。它也无法判断这种疗法是否能治疗这类问题，因为你只是把它称为创伤后应激障碍（PTSD），但实际上PTSD包含四种不同的情况。那么到底是这四种里的哪一种呢？仅仅看PTSD的诊断没有任何意义。我同意这种批评。我并不完全认同美国国家心理健康研究所（NIMH）
on a ton of stuff, but I don't think that's wrong because, I mean, he may be right. for the wrong reasons there, but like PTSD where? Like is it somatic re-experiencing? Is it a mood dysregulation? Is it, um, is it a relational, um, you know, projection and attack like type of type of antagonism there that's not quite a personality disorder? Because if somebody has an unfair expectation about relationships from trauma, um, and
在很多事情上的做法，但我认为这种批评并非完全错误，因为，我的意思是，他可能在某些方面是对的，尽管理由可能不对。比如PTSD到底是什么？是躯体化的重现体验吗？是情绪失调吗？是那种人际关系中的投射和攻击，或者是一种不完全属于人格障碍的对抗性行为吗？因为如果某人因为创伤而对人际关系抱有不公平的期望，并且
they're, you know, like trying to control other people with whatever because they don't feel like safe if whatever and that comes from a trauma, not like an early attachment thing. it's not a personality disorder. It is PTSD. You're going to treat that type of PTSD completely different from flashback re-experiencing. And you're going to treat both of those types differently than somebody who has, you know, somatic overwhelm and like mood dysregulation and panic type trauma.
他们试图用各种方式控制他人，因为如果事情不如意他们就会感到不安全，而这源于创伤，而不是早期的依恋问题，那这就不是人格障碍，而是PTSD。你治疗那种PTSD的方式与治疗闪回重现体验的方式完全不同。你治疗这两种类型的方式，也与治疗那些有躯体化过载、情绪失调和恐慌型创伤的人的方式不同。
Like that's going to be a different kind of therapy. Maybe they have all three, maybe they have two of them. But haven't done this for a long time. Those are different types of memory. The type of your brain that thinks of yourself as the story is a different memory process than the one that like, you know, hears voices indrospectively and like,
那将是完全不同的疗法。也许他们三种都有，也许有两种。但我很久没这么做了。这些是不同类型的记忆。你大脑中将自己视为故事主角的那部分，其记忆过程与那种内省时听到声音的记忆过程是不同的，
remembers these relational things than the type that is like relational memory. And that's different from the like deep implicit embodied emotions of how your body remembers to feel emotion. There's a lot of neurology that backs up my point, but I'm not going to go on like a defense of that. But like you see those things different clinically. Neuroscience also indicates that those memory systems are kind of different. So like my ax to grind is like,
那种记忆关系事物的方式，与人际关系记忆是不同的。这又与那种深层的、隐含的、具身化的情绪记忆不同，即你的身体如何记住感受情绪。有很多神经学证据支持我的观点，但我不想在这里进行辩护。但你在临床上确实能看到这些不同的东西。神经科学也表明这些记忆系统是不同的。所以我的不满在于，
why are we just calling all of that PTSD? What type of memory is the trauma end? How did it get there? And what symptoms is like? causing even the new PTSD diagnosis just don't do that well um so uh look you know we talked in that other episode that I did um about like borderline personality disorder is it's strange because it's this like weird um fossil of these older systems that they're trying to fit into the new one because it's very useful for certain types of clinicians to conceive of that um but then it doesn't
为什么我们要把所有这些都统称为PTSD？创伤到底属于哪种记忆？它是怎么形成的？它导致了什么症状？即使是新的PTSD诊断标准也做得不够好。所以，你看，我们在上一集里谈到过边缘型人格障碍，这很奇怪，因为它就像是旧系统留下的一个奇怪的化石，他们试图把它硬塞进新系统里，因为对于某些临床医生来说，这样构思它非常有用，但它
really fit with any of the new assumptions that we're making. So how do we say, like, the old assumptions were wrong, except they sort of got this one right? How do you do that? You can't? Because borderline originally comes about when they're saying, hey, there's psychotics who are totally not in reality. And then there's neurotics who are in reality, but they're suffering and have these, you know, emotional distresses. And then there's borderlines that are in the middle, the border, that's where the term comes from, the border between neurosis and psychosis, where they're in on planet Earth most of the time. But then all of a sudden, reality becomes plastic when they feel one emotion and then they they're not lying they really
实际上并不符合我们现在所做的任何新假设。那么我们该怎么说呢？旧的假设是错的，但他们却在这一点上做对了？你怎么做到这一点？你做不到。因为边缘型人格障碍最初的由来是，他们说，嘿，有完全脱离现实的精神病患者，还有身处现实但正在受苦并有情绪困扰的神经症患者。然后还有处于中间的边缘型患者，这就是“边缘”这个词的由来，即神经症和精神病之间的边缘，他们大部分时间都在地球上。但突然间，当他们感受到某种情绪时，现实就变得可塑了，然后他们——他们不是在撒谎，他们真的
believe it um so we can't say that they're lying but also the things that they believe you know there's six people there we all see it it didn't happen that way they felt attacked but nobody really attacked them actually they were the problem and then they deflected and confabulated a new version later that matched their self-image so what do we do with these people because we can't call them psychotic because they don't have schizophrenia and we can't call them neurotic because this is more than an anxiety disorder but then you change to a checklist system and then you still keep it and then you go back to spectrum and it's trying to be conceived of in all these ways you know what is the border on a spectrum right um so you have all of those things happening and there's a ton of secrecy
相信这一点。所以我们不能说他们在撒谎，但他们所相信的事情，你知道，那里有六个人，我们都看到了，事情并不是那样发生的。他们感到被攻击，但实际上没有人攻击他们，其实他们自己才是问题所在，然后他们转移了话题，并在事后编造了一个符合他们自我形象的新版本。那么我们该如何对待这些人呢？因为我们不能称他们为精神病患者，因为他们没有精神分裂症；我们也不能称他们为神经症患者，因为这不仅仅是焦虑症。但后来你改成了清单系统，然后你又保留了它，接着又回到了谱系概念，它试图以各种方式被构思，你知道，什么是谱系上的边缘，对吧？所以所有这些事情都在发生，而且有大量的保密性。
again with the dsm five um you know the dsm five was like the most secretive uh enclosed of all the processes which again i don't think they did for nefarious reasons um i think they did it to keep the public as not a and in the news too largely because with the DOS and four one of the things that happened is they had these committee meetings about how they were going to get rid of Asperger's and it like leaked to the news or it wasn't a secret so it was available for the news and then everybody freaked out and started like writing all these articles and being like all these people aren't going to have care and like I can't work because my son gets these federal benefits of psychiatrists delete them then I won't get money they wanted to avoid that for the five so that they didn't have to be in
再说回DSM-5，你知道，DSM-5是所有流程中最隐秘、最封闭的一个，我再次声明，我不认为他们是出于恶意，我认为他们这样做是为了不让公众参与，也不让新闻界介入，很大程度上是因为在DSM-4的时候，发生的一件事是他们召开了关于如何取消阿斯伯格综合征的委员会会议，结果泄露给了新闻界，或者说它不是秘密，所以新闻界可以获取，然后每个人都吓坏了，开始写各种文章，说这些人将得不到照顾，说“我无法工作，因为我儿子靠这些联邦福利生活，如果精神科医生删除了它，我就拿不到钱了”。他们想在DSM-5中避免这种情况，这样他们就不必与公众进行
conversation with the public and the public's didn't have the ability to influence the process by like heckling or interacting with the people or writing about what they're talking about as they're talking about it. And a lot of the things that they added in the four and five for children, I think are entirely made up ways for parents to diagnose something is wrong with this child instead of like, how does the environment support the child? I don't really like any of the child think, but I'm not a child psychologist, so I'm not an expert in that also. Who cares what I think? But when you go through, you know, at the end of this, one of the reasons why I want to cover the history of how it got here is like I've seen a ton of hostility to the DSM, but no one's allowed to talk about it because we all have to like largely build insurance and be professional. And so again, I'm not saying this is my opinion.
对话，公众也就没有能力通过起哄、与相关人员互动或在他们讨论时撰写相关文章来影响这一过程。我认为他们在DSM-4和DSM-5中为儿童增加的许多东西，完全是父母为了诊断孩子有问题而编造出来的，而不是去思考环境如何支持孩子。我不太喜欢任何关于儿童的诊断，但我不是儿童心理学家，所以我也不是那方面的专家。谁在乎我的想法呢？但在最后，我想要回顾这一切是如何走到今天这一步的原因之一是，我看到了对DSM的大量敌意，但没有人被允许谈论它，因为我们都必须在很大程度上依靠保险来维持生计并保持专业。所以再次声明，我并不是说这是我的观点。
I'm just kind of giving you a lay of the land and how it gets here. But you see hostility to the DSM in my experience and like about half of clinicians hate it or don't care. about it. But it's the thing that we're all supposed to be using and do use to some extent. And like when I was in training, I was like shocked because I went to somebody I won't name, but they were the person that was in charge of me when I got out of school. Or they were in a supervisory capacity. And like multiple people were like, yeah, I don't care about the diagnoses because I have this one ax to grind against the DSM. It doesn't make sense anyway. So just put something you can build and then move on. I'm doing this on the behalf of
我只是在向你介绍情况以及它是如何走到这一步的。但在我的经验中，你确实能看到对DSM的敌意，大约一半的临床医生讨厌它或者根本不在乎它。但它是我们所有人都应该使用，并且在某种程度上确实在使用的东西。当我还在受训时，我感到很震惊，因为我去找了一个人——我不会说出名字，但当我刚毕业时，他是负责管理我的人，或者他担任督导职务。好几个人都说：“是的，我不在乎诊断，因为我对DSM有意见。反正它也没什么意义。所以随便填个能报销的诊断，然后继续工作就行了。”我这样做是代表
an institution. I'm not talking about Tapread or any individual practice I've ever been on. This was at the instruction of psychiatrists and stuff. So it's not like, it wasn't my decision. That's what I was told to do. But I was like, what? We were taught it was the gold standard of evidence and all this stuff. And then you enter the workforce and really high up people are saying like, I don't care about it. So like one of the things that the diagnosis, one of the points I want to make is the DSM has created this paradox where there's diagnosis as treated as both this identity defining thing.
一个机构。我不是在谈论Tapread或我曾经工作过的任何个人诊所。这是在精神科医生的指导下进行的。所以这不是我的决定。这就是我被告知要做的。但我当时想，什么？我们受到的教育是它是证据的黄金标准等等。然后你进入职场，真正的高层人士却说，我不在乎它。所以，我想提出的关于诊断的观点之一是，DSM创造了一个悖论，即诊断既被视为一种定义身份的东西，
But it's also utterly meaningless at the same time. And a lot of people treat diagnosis like it's a horoscope or worse, this excuse to behave however they want. Oh, I have to do that. I have autism. I have to do that in Portland. It's like, no, man, like, if you can give me like a 30 minute explanation of all the things that I need to do to enable you as a stranger in a store, then like maybe you're not neurodivergent
但同时又完全没有意义。很多人把诊断当作星座运势，甚至更糟，当作随心所欲行事的借口。“哦，我必须那样做，我有自闭症。我必须在波特兰那样做。”这就像是，不，伙计，如果你能给我一个30分钟的解释，说明我作为一个店里的陌生人需要做些什么来配合你，那么也许你并没有那么神经多样性，
enough to like warrant my participant. Like, I'm respectful to everybody. I'm a trauma-informed therapist. I'm talking about where people use basically. diagnoses that they have is when people weaponize the language of psychotherapy because of the internet or these Facebook support groups or whatever to get other people to do what they want when they could do for themselves and I'm not like a you know bootstraps cut Medicaid person like hopefully you know that if you're watching the show I'm talking about abuse when somebody is disguising themselves as the victim
以至于需要我的配合。我对每个人都很尊重。我是一名创伤知情治疗师。我谈论的是人们如何利用他们所拥有的诊断，当人们因为互联网或Facebook支持小组等原因武器化心理治疗的语言，来让别人做他们想做的事，而他们本可以自己做的时候。我不是那种“靠自己努力、削减医疗补助”的人，希望如果你在看这个节目就知道这一点。我谈论的是虐待，当有人用心理学的语言伪装成受害者时，
with the language of psychology and because a lot of people do that it makes diagnosis like look worse. And so, you know, some people cling to it, the diagnosis. They define themselves by it. Like I said, you know, some people want a diagnosis, but no treatment, which again doesn't make sense to me. And then the other, and they orient their whole self concept around a diagnosis, which is never what it was supposed to be or is, but the public perceives it that way. And then other therapists and patients have been diagnosed with so many things. They've been to the ER 20 times in three states and they've gotten 20 diagnoses in the last 15 years and they're just like it's all BS. It doesn't matter because nobody even knows what it is.
因为很多人这样做，这让诊断看起来更糟糕。所以，你知道，有些人紧紧抓住诊断不放。他们用它来定义自己。就像我说的，有些人想要诊断，但不要治疗，这对我来说也说不通。还有另一类人，他们被诊断出患有各种疾病。他们在三个州去了20次急诊室，在过去15年里得到了20个诊断，他们只是觉得这全是胡扯。这无关紧要，因为根本没人知道那是什么。
They tell me to have a different thing every time I switch psychiatrists, which is true. Like if you want to make an argument that this thing is scientific at all, everything they did to three was to make it more valid and psychiatrists still don't agree on any of this stuff. So if they don't agree and everyone's getting different diagnosis from different psychiatrists, then you either have to say one of two things is true. one, the book doesn't really work, or two, American medicine is in comp, the book does work, and American medicine is incompetent at applying it. So the system doesn't work.
他们告诉我，每次我换精神科医生，诊断结果都不一样，这是事实。如果你想争辩说这东西有科学性，那么他们在DSM-3中所做的一切都是为了使其更有效，但精神科医生仍然对所有这些东西意见不一。所以如果他们意见不一，而且每个人从不同的精神科医生那里得到不同的诊断，那么你必须承认以下两点之一：第一，这本书根本没用；或者第二，美国医学界无能，书是有用的，但美国医学界在应用它时很无能。所以这个系统行不通。
But you can't continue to pretend that these things work, because how can that be true, that this thing is completely valid and reliable and consistent? And then half of my patients that have switched psychiatrists a couple times and been to the R a couple times have nine different diagnoses with no overlap that are wildly different. Like, I'm not talking about like bipolar versus schizophrenia or schizoaffective versus bipolar. I'm talking about way all over the book. How does that happen? Right. But if you know the answer to that question, email me. But like, there also seems to be this pervasive belief among patients that a diagnosis is this permanent thing that all clinicians have access to because
但你不能继续假装这些东西有效，因为如果这东西完全有效、可靠且一致，怎么会发生这种情况呢？我有一半的病人换过几次精神科医生，去过几次急诊室，他们有九个不同的诊断，没有任何重叠，而且差异巨大。我不是在谈论双相情感障碍与精神分裂症，或者分裂情感性障碍与双相情感障碍的区别。我说的是书里完全不同的诊断。这是怎么发生的？对吧。但如果你知道这个问题的答案，请给我发邮件。但似乎在病人中也存在一种普遍的信念，认为诊断是一种永久性的东西，所有临床医生都能访问，因为
we've made it so important and that if you get it, it'll follow you for your whole life. I've had so many people that are like, I don't want to go to therapy because I don't want you to diagnose me with this because if you get diagnosed with borderline or if you get diagnosed with this, you. And that's, you get diagnosed with then you'll have it for the rest of your life. And I'm like, no, if you have schizophrenia, you'll have it for the rest of your life. If I diagnose you with schizophrenia and you don't have it, you're not going to get it.
我们把它看得太重要了，如果你得到了它，它会跟随你一辈子。我遇到过很多人说：“我不想去治疗，因为我不想让你给我诊断这个，因为如果你被诊断为边缘型人格障碍，或者如果你被诊断为这个，你……”然后就是，你被诊断了，你这辈子就带着它了。我说，不，如果你有精神分裂症，你这辈子确实会有它。如果我诊断你患有精神分裂症而你并没有，你也不会真的患上它。
But other doctors will think that, not unless you tell them or you give me a release of information to send your records to that guy. There's not like one club we all hang out at. There's not like one giant medical record that we all log into and look at. Like, it's your medical record. Unless a court tells me that I gives me a HIPAA waiver
但其他医生会那样认为，除非你告诉他们，或者你给我一份信息发布授权书，让我把你的记录发给那个人。我们并没有一个大家都在一起聚会的俱乐部。没有一个巨大的医疗记录系统是我们所有人都能登录并查看的。那是你的医疗记录。除非法院告诉我，给我一份HIPAA豁免书，
and says that I have to give it to a judge or you sign an ROI. It's not going anywhere. But again, there's this perception that it's the most important thing because the profit motive is treating it that way. So patients assign this mysticism to it. That it must be important when I think it's probably one of the least important things. You know, if we didn't have a DSM, I still think I could get where I was going with patients. I wouldn't be sitting there being like, well, I don't know what they have.
并说我必须把它交给法官，或者你签署了一份ROI（信息发布授权书）。它哪儿也不会去。但同样，人们有一种感知，认为它是最重要的东西，因为利润动机就是这样对待它的。所以病人赋予了它神秘感。当我认为它可能是最不重要的事情之一时，他们觉得它一定很重要。你知道，如果我们没有DSM，我仍然认为我能达到治疗病人的目的。我不会坐在那里想，好吧，我不知道他们有什么病，
So how could I possibly treat them? The only scientific way to deal with anxiety is not to tell somebody to relax or relate to them or see where it comes from or how often it happens or like, you know, what part of their body does it live in? Or what does it do to their posture if I tell them to experience it in the room and then share my observation? I don't want to do any of that. If I don't have a diagnosis of the type of anxiety they have and then I can't go be told based on that diagnosis, what's evidence based? How could I ever treat anxiety? I mean, nothing can be self-evident. I think it's the least important part because if you burned the book, I could still probably do psychotherapy on you. And not because the book,
所以我怎么可能治疗他们？处理焦虑的唯一科学方法不是告诉某人放松，或者与他们建立联系，或者看看它来自哪里，或者它发生的频率，或者，你知道，它存在于他们身体的哪个部位？或者如果我告诉他们在房间里体验它，然后分享我的观察，它会对他们的姿势产生什么影响？我不想做任何这些。如果我没有他们所患焦虑类型的诊断，那么我就不能根据那个诊断被告知什么是循证的。我怎么可能治疗焦虑？我的意思是，没有什么是不言自明的。我认为这是最不重要的一部分，因为如果你烧了那本书，我可能仍然可以对你进行心理治疗。而不是因为那本书
ever existed, you know, like, I use the DSM, but I'm just saying I don't think that that is the most important part of your treatment with me. So to combat this inflation of diagnosis that the checklist cause, Alan Francis and the DSM-4 task force, they introduced this clinical significance criteria. So they say to receive a diagnosis, the symptoms will must cause clinically significant distress or impairment and social, occupational, or other important areas of functioning. and their intent was to create this gatekeeping mechanism where it's like look don't read about this thing on webmd or facebook or hear that your friend got diagnosed and then decide like oh my gosh i once was nervous i'm a neurotic and then go to try and get a diagnosis um like during coven like one of the things
曾经存在过，你知道，我使用DSM，但我只是说我不认为这是你与我治疗过程中最重要的一部分。为了对抗清单导致的诊断膨胀，艾伦·弗朗西斯（Alan Frances）和DSM-4工作组引入了临床显著性标准。所以他们说，要获得诊断，症状必须在社交、职业或其他重要功能领域引起临床显著的痛苦或损害。他们的意图是建立这种把关机制，就像是，看，不要在WebMD或Facebook上阅读关于这个东西的内容，或者听说你的朋友被诊断了，然后就决定，哦天哪，我曾经紧张过，我是一个神经症患者，然后去试图获得一个诊断。比如在新冠疫情期间，
that would come up in the consultation groups like nationally if i asked people it was like all these people were like basically getting depressed and anxious sometimes because they were you know shut in during COVID. Some people like that. But I think sometimes because they had to spend time with their family all day. And because of the anxiety, they decided they had ADHD and they all got on like Rital while they were like at home. And that like happened nationally during COVID. Like a lot of therapists talked about it with me.
在全国范围内的咨询小组中出现的一件事是，如果我问人们，他们会说所有这些人基本上因为在新冠期间被关在家里而变得抑郁和焦虑。有些人喜欢那样。但我认为有时是因为他们不得不整天和家人待在一起。由于焦虑，他们决定自己患有ADHD，然后他们在家里都开始服用利他林。这在新冠期间在全国范围内发生了。很多治疗师和我谈论过这件事。
And it's like, I don't know. So I'm sorry. I'm losing my train of thought. But so Alan Francis with the DSM, you know, four when he's saying, that the gatekeeping mechanism is trying to stop people from doing that. Like, don't just be in a situation that makes you nervous and then decide, do you have an anxiety disorder?
这就像，我不知道。所以很抱歉。我思路断了。但艾伦·弗朗西斯在DSM-4中说，把关机制是为了阻止人们这样做。就像，不要仅仅因为处于一个让你紧张的环境中，就决定你患有焦虑症。
But the problem with it is when you tie suffering to behavior, when people are higher functioning or they're more resilient, or they're a little bit brighter or a little bit more emotionally intelligent, and they're coping better, you exclude people who are suffering, but they're not acting on it because they're mature or they're, you know, more capable, from treatment. I mean, some of the sickest people that I've ever seen, like with a dissociative
但它的问题在于，当你把痛苦与行为联系起来时，当人们功能更高、更具韧性，或者更聪明、情绪智力更高，并且应对得更好时，你就把那些正在受苦但因为成熟或更有能力而没有表现出来的人排除在治疗之外了。我的意思是，我见过的一些最痛苦的人，比如患有解离性
disorder or something, it was so compartmentalized where they were so afraid of being the abuser, they made sure that that suffering never hurt anybody. They never turned it outward. They never abused anybody. They took care of everybody. But then they went in private and they hurt themselves with alcohol or with dissociation with panic attacks and they built routines so that this didn't interfere with their functioning. But they were still, you know, emotionally in hell. So I think that the point of psychology is to treat suffering, not to say, go behave badly and then we'll fix your behavior so you can go back to work. I have a big issue with that conceptualization of like, you know, you are a cog in the grease and capitalist steam engine. And your only job is to, you know, make that thing work.
障碍的人，他们的情况非常区隔化，他们非常害怕成为施虐者，他们确保这种痛苦从不伤害任何人。他们从不向外发泄。他们从不虐待任何人。他们照顾每个人。但随后他们私下里用酒精或通过解离、恐慌发作来伤害自己，他们建立了常规，这样就不会干扰他们的功能。但他们仍然，你知道，在情感上处于地狱中。所以我认为心理学的意义在于治疗痛苦，而不是说，去表现得糟糕一点，然后我们会修复你的行为，这样你就可以回去工作了。我对那种“你是一个资本主义蒸汽机里的齿轮，你唯一的工作就是让那个东西运转”的概念化有很大的意见。
We don't really care how you feel. That seems like a scary direction for psychology to go. So, you know, who benefits from a diagnostic system that only represents. recognizes suffering when it impairs productivity. Insurance companies benefit because if you're, you know, working, then basically there's a lot of reasons why they don't have to pay for your treatment. Employers benefit because they don't have to accommodate workers that have something that's not affecting their output and the economy benefits because you have a lot of people who don't
我们并不真正关心你的感受。这似乎是心理学发展的一个可怕方向。所以，你知道，谁从一个只在痛苦影响生产力时才承认痛苦的诊断系统中受益？保险公司受益，因为如果你在工作，那么基本上他们有很多理由不必支付你的治疗费用。雇主受益，因为他们不必为那些患有不影响产出的疾病的员工提供便利，经济也受益，因为你有很多人不会
take time off work to do things. But I don't know that that's true because I don't think in the long run the economy benefits from people suffering some of the time. but you know who doesn't benefit the person who's coming in to receive care the patient if a human being is suffering and they're told that suffering doesn't count because they can still work you're gaslighting people who may be some of the most sick people except they're more compassionate because they don't want to hurt other people or affect other people who depend on them and so they're internalizing a lot of suffering but it's still real just because you can't see
请假去做这些事情。但我不知道这是不是真的，因为我不认为从长远来看，经济会从人们时不时受苦中受益。但你知道谁不受益吗？那个进来接受护理的人，病人。如果一个人正在受苦，而他们被告知这种痛苦不算数，因为他们还能工作，你就是在对那些可能病得最重的人进行煤气灯操纵，只是因为他们更富有同情心，因为他们不想伤害别人或影响依赖他们的人，所以他们内化了大量的痛苦，但这仍然是真实的。仅仅因为你看不到
it doesn't mean it's not real just because you can't count it doesn't make it's not real and you have some clinicians who are like well if it doesn't show up on the scale, how do you see it? And it's like, just because you can't see it doesn't mean it's not real. And there's some people who came in for a session and they're telling me how great they are. And I'm like, man, are you okay? You know, and then they just start crying because they're not. They're coming in to tell me about how great they're doing and how in control they are. But it's not true. And it's the clinician's job to see that it's not true and give them the chance to be honest about it. So what would like a more humane criterion work? Do I have anything
它，并不意味着它不是真实的。仅仅因为你无法计算它，并不意味着它不是真实的。有些病人来做咨询，他们告诉我他们有多好。我说，伙计，你还好吗？你知道，然后他们就开始哭，因为他们并不好。他们进来告诉我他们做得有多好，他们有多么掌控局面。但这不是真的。临床医生的工作就是看出这不是真的，并给他们机会诚实地面对它。那么，一个更人道的标准会是什么样的呢？我有什么
to say other than whining about the history and weighing in on like what I think of all the participants in the process of history. I mean, I think a truly patient-centered diagnostic system would not ask, can you work? It would ask, are you suffering? The sud, the subjective unit of distress, is a lot more important than we've made it. And if the answer is yes, then that should be enough, suffering's indication for treatment. I think one of the biggest failures is that we know the brain is like mesh networks and how it works. And because we know it's networked, it's like affecting these kind of
要说的吗，除了抱怨历史并对我在历史进程中的所有参与者的看法发表意见？我的意思是，我认为一个真正以病人为中心的诊断系统不会问：你能工作吗？它会问：你在受苦吗？主观痛苦单位（SUD）比我们所认为的要重要得多。如果答案是肯定的，那么这就应该足够了，痛苦本身就是治疗的指征。我认为最大的失败之一是我们知道大脑就像网状网络，它是如何工作的。因为我们知道它是联网的，它会影响这些
regions. And a lot of the problem with the brain, the DSM5 was that the QEG research and the MRI research where they thought that they would have ways to like map these symptoms onto biomarkers or these diagnoses on the biomarkers. When they really got it in, the other people who like don't like that form of empiricism because it's a little bit subjective, like tore it to shreds, we think. And then they weren't able to use all this data and research that they said that they were going to use when they did it. So if they didn't use it, somebody didn't like And if you look at those lists of people, you can probably tell what the sides of these arguments are. But one of the things that I don't understand is that I read a lot of neuroscience and cognitive science because I think it's interesting and they're doing a lot of the work that psychology used to do, academic psychology used to do, is like they make theories about processes in the brain because based on results that they get in subjective intuitions.
区域。DSM-5在大脑问题上的很大一部分是，QEG（定量脑电图）研究和MRI研究，他们认为他们会有方法将这些症状映射到生物标志物上，或者将这些诊断映射到生物标志物上。当他们真正深入研究时，那些不喜欢这种经验主义形式的人——因为它有点主观——把它撕得粉碎。然后他们无法使用他们说在做的时候要使用的所有这些数据和研究。所以如果他们没用它，有人不喜欢。如果你看那些名单，你可能就能看出这些争论的双方是什么。但我无法理解的一件事是，我阅读了大量的神经科学和认知科学，因为我觉得它很有趣，而且他们正在做心理学过去做的工作，学术心理学过去做的工作，就是他们根据在主观直觉中得到的结果，对大脑中的过程做出理论。
But there's not a way to measure a lot of these things. Like QEG has a lot of limitations. Like, fMRI has like wonderful structural resolution, but it takes forever to get. So you're missing this data with QEG. You can see within the fraction of a millisecond, but you have these 13 electrodes. They're on the top of the brain. And a lot of people, and we're basing this on an assumption that I think is true, that you can make determinations because the brain is networked based on what's happening
但没有办法测量很多这些东西。比如QEG有很多局限性。比如，fMRI有很棒的结构分辨率，但获取它需要很长时间。所以你错过了这些数据。通过QEG，你可以在几分之一毫秒内看到，但你有这13个电极。它们在大脑顶部。很多人，我们基于一个我认为是正确的假设，即你可以做出判断，因为大脑是联网的，基于正在发生的事情
on the top level of the neurons. You can make determinations about what's happening. excuse me at deeper levels inside of the brain. Like one of the, and that when you could, and we know that that is happening because when we stimulate the outside of the brain, the deep brain changes, you know, like on scans.
在神经元的顶层。你可以对正在发生的事情做出判断，抱歉，在大脑内部更深层的地方。比如其中一个，当你能做到时，我们知道这是正在发生的，因为当我们刺激大脑外部时，深层大脑会发生变化，你知道，在扫描中。
So we know that that's true, but there's this like, oh, we can't see it yet, so we can't believe it's real. Well, you're just not ever really going to be able to see everything in psychology. Like you can't.
所以我们知道这是真的，但存在这种“哦，我们还看不到它，所以我们不能相信它是真的”的想法。好吧，你永远无法真正看到心理学中的一切。你不能。
You have to kind of feel how things work. And, you know, I've said before, like even in quantum physics, that's kind of how a lot of people are discovering things is intuitively, even though ultimately they got to justify. it with math, the discovery happens there. And a lot of these discoveries aren't allowed in this process anymore because of the bureaucratic nature of how they're fused together on these committees.
你必须去感受事情是如何运作的。而且，你知道，我之前说过，即使在量子物理学中，这也是很多人发现事物的方式，是直觉上的，尽管最终他们必须用数学来证明它。发现就在那里发生。而由于这些委员会在官僚性质上的融合方式，很多这些发现不再被允许进入这个过程。
So why can't psychotherapy, you know, have this same conceptual flexibility as the harder sciences that are studying the same organ? Like, why? And I think a lot of times the answer is academic insecurity. Like I was told I can't talk about anything other than my specialization and my specialization, you know, bumps up against another one. So I have to retreat back into mine instead of fusing them together. And another one is this insecurity of like, well, I can't be taken seriously unless I'm acting on completely empirical information. Well, guess what? Your need to do that is a subjective bias that most of the time is wrong. So your need to be this logical being is being fueled by an emotional energy. So like we are always running on emotion, man. Like you can't take the
那么为什么心理治疗不能像研究同一个器官的硬科学那样具有相同的概念灵活性呢？为什么？我认为很多时候答案是学术上的不安全感。就像我被告知我不能谈论除我的专业以外的任何事情，而我的专业，你知道，与另一个专业相撞。所以我必须退回到我的专业中，而不是将它们融合在一起。另一个是这种不安全感，即“好吧，除非我基于完全经验性的信息行事，否则我不会被认真对待”。好吧，猜猜怎么着？你这样做的需要是一种主观偏见，大多数时候是错误的。所以你成为这种逻辑存在的需要是由一种情感能量驱动的。所以我们总是靠情感运行，伙计。你不能把
subjectivity out of science, not this type of science. And, you know, at this point, you can look like in a computer of any major medical system, and you can see the frequent flyer with hundreds of diagnosis. So you just have to make the case that the checklist doesn't work. That isn't, that drawing lines around clusters of symptoms isn't really going to get you anywhere scientific. It's not going to get you where any scientific, it's not going to get you anywhere scientific when you're trying to find out the back end, the why, these things are there.
主观性从科学中剔除，不是这种科学。而且，你知道，在这一点上，你可以查看任何大型医疗系统的计算机，你可以看到有数百个诊断的“常客”。所以你只需要证明清单不起作用。在症状群周围画线并不能让你在科学上取得任何进展。当你试图找出后端，即为什么这些东西存在时，它不会让你在科学上取得任何进展。
And it's not going to get you anywhere scientific when you're trying to figure out the how-to of treating them, you know, clinically, because as we do this, the outcomes get weirder and worse. But then also, like, it doesn't tell you how to get to, like, a better understanding of what the disorder is because you decide, you're the one that created it. You drew the box around the symptoms. And then you expect this other information to materialize. Well, it's been a long time since 1980. And it hasn't done that yet. So let's rethink the system. And then the document itself has these contradicting assumptions, like I was saying. It tries to pivot in one direction, but then those pivots get held up by committee that can't agree,
当你试图弄清楚在临床上治疗它们的“如何做”时，它也不会让你在科学上取得任何进展，因为当我们这样做时，结果变得越来越奇怪和糟糕。但同时，它也没有告诉你如何更好地理解这种障碍是什么，因为是你决定了，是你创造了它。你在症状周围画了框。然后你期望这些其他信息实现。好吧，从1980年到现在已经很久了。它还没有做到这一点。所以让我们重新思考这个系统。而且文档本身有相互矛盾的假设，就像我说的。它试图向一个方向旋转，但这些旋转被无法达成一致的委员会搁置了，
so they end up with an incomplete vision, but then this other part is assuming a different thing. Or, I mean, the end of the book, like a lot of that spectrum disorder is basically telling you to ignore the stuff that is canon, the stuff that's in the appendix of like, yeah, consider this. But what you're telling me to consider is contradicting the thing that you're saying is real in the actual book. And again, you know, this is a diagnostic. manual. So it's not like you have to read between the lines in order to see these things. Like they're not going to tell them themselves and say like do two different things that are opposite. But a lot of ways that ESM5 is telling you to do that. It's a Dagwood sandwich of a bunch
所以他们最终得到了一个不完整的愿景，但另一部分却假设了不同的东西。或者，我的意思是，书的结尾，像很多那种谱系障碍，基本上是在告诉你忽略那些经典的东西，那些在附录里的东西，比如“是的，考虑这个”。但你让我考虑的东西与你在书中实际说的是真实的东西相矛盾。而且再次声明，你知道，这是一个诊断手册。所以并不是说你必须在字里行间阅读才能看到这些东西。它们不会自己说出来，说“做两件相反的事情”。但DSM-5在很多方面都在告诉你这样做。它是一堆
of theories that don't really go together. And you know, there's also one of the reasons why this is that they won't look at is they want to have psychiatrists on these panels, but they also want to have clinical psychologists. But obviously the psychiatrists have more power. And they also want to have social workers, but obviously the clinical psychologists are taken more seriously and have a little bit more power than the social workers, the LPCs. I mean, hell, the LPs is probably treated more seriously than the social workers. But, you know, when you read like Yolam, or somebody who's like the gateway drug that brought a ton of people into this profession, Yolam was the gateway drug for a lot of people in my generation, like he was doing therapy for an hour before we ever adjusted medication.
并不真正合拍的理论的“达格伍德三明治”。你知道，这也是他们不愿看的原因之一，他们想在这些小组中加入精神科医生，但他们也想加入临床心理学家。但显然精神科医生拥有更多的权力。他们也想加入社会工作者，但显然临床心理学家比社会工作者、LPC（持证专业咨询师）更受重视，拥有更多的权力。我的意思是，见鬼，LP（持证心理学家）可能比社会工作者更受重视。但是，你知道，当你读像亚隆（Yalom）这样的人，或者像那种把很多人带入这个行业的人，亚隆是我那一代很多人的入门毒药，他在我们调整药物之前，已经做了整整一个小时的治疗。
And he was doing therapy weekly. Psychiatrists don't do that anymore. So maybe one of the things that we should just, I don't think that's a good system. But like, if we're going to do that as an, because of our economic engine, if we're going to do that because of the structural hierarchies of the hospital, the psychiatrist probably has never been in therapy. They probably have never done therapy. And if they have, it's going to be like CBT or DBT at a student counseling center or something, you know, and I'm talking about the vast majority. I'm not saying that there's no psychiatrist out that that does this. I'm saying all of the incentive structure of our world made sure that this stuff changed drastically from how it, used to work, and the incentive
而且他每周都在做治疗。精神科医生现在不再那样做了。所以也许我们应该做的其中一件事，我不认为那是一个好的系统。但如果我们要因为我们的经济引擎而这样做，如果我们要因为医院的结构等级而这样做，精神科医生可能从来没有接受过治疗。他们可能从来没有做过治疗。如果他们做过，那也会是学生咨询中心之类的CBT或DBT，你知道，我说的是绝大多数。我不是说没有做这个的精神科医生。我说的是我们世界的所有激励结构都确保了这些东西与过去的工作方式发生了巨大的变化，而激励
structure will control most of what happens. If you're going to do that, then maybe you need a different manual for conceptualizing medication and therapy. Because there's not that much overlap anymore. So if there is, they're two different jobs. I don't think they should
结构将控制发生的大部分事情。如果你要那样做，那么也许你需要一本不同的手册来构思药物和治疗。因为现在没有那么多的重叠了。所以如果有，它们是两份不同的工作。我不认为它们应该是，但如果你要让它们成为两份不同的工作，也许你需要两本不同的工作手册。所以如果你今天遇到一个正在做治疗的精神科医生，你很可能会发现他们大约80岁左右，因为没有人能负担得起，我的意思是，医院根本不想有精神科。他们必须有，但他们想做的是，如果你看到一个医院做广告的广告牌，那将是关于接生
be, but if you're going to make them two different jobs, maybe you need two different job manuals. So if you meet a psychiatrist that's doing therapy today, you're likely to find that they're like 80 or something, because nobody can afford, I mean, hospitals don't want to have psychiatry at all. They have to, but what they want to do, like if you see a billboard where hospitals advertising, it's going to be for delivering
婴儿，或者不是治愈，而是治疗癌症，因为那是他们赚钱的地方。那是他们可以收取所有这些费用的地方。你知道，精神科，如果可以的话，他们会摆脱它，但他们必须有它。但没有人真正想做它。我的意思是，有人觉得有使命感去做它，进入它，但它不是那种高收入的事情，因为我们转向了这个基于服务的系统，他们看着精神科，他们就像“服务在哪里？这全都是谈话，即使是精神药理学，也只是你问他们这些问题，所以服务在哪里？”所以，你知道，整个系统就是我猜我在上一集中遗漏的细节。你知道，我谈到了Starrgy研究。我谈到了很多事情，这些都是
babies or not curing, but treating cancer, because that's where they make money. That's what they can charge all this money for. You know, psychiatry, they would get rid of if they could, but they got to have it. But nobody really wants to do it. I mean, there's people that feel called to do it, go into it but it's not like one of the high earning things because we moved to this service-based system and they're looking at psychiatry and they're like where's the service it's all just like talk even psychopharm it's just like you asking them these questions so like where's the service um so you know there's the that whole system is i guess the detail that i lost left out of the last episode. You know, I talked about the Starrgy study. I talked about a lot of the things that are
系统不太工作的迹象。但这就是历史。这就是它最终走到这一步的方式。所以，我的意思是，你该怎么办？我的意思是，我认为你可以重新使主观性合法化，作为一种发现和组织事物的有效方式。你知道，很多人觉得一定有某种共同的变量，也许是间接通路调节。这是一个相当不错的理论，即感觉门控很差。所以，你知道，应该被过滤掉的信息没有被过滤掉。所以你得到了这种强大的直觉。而那种间接通路，它在那些更神秘、更古怪的人身上，你知道，也许更有可能在自闭症谱系上，但也可能有某种多巴胺障碍，这些东西应该放在一起。我的意思是，那将是一种方式
indications that the system doesn't quite work. But this is the history. This is how it ended up in the place that it ended up. So, I mean, what do you do? I mean, I think you can re-legitimize subjectivity as just a valid way to discover and organize things. You know, a lot of people feel like there must be sort of some common variable that maybe is indirect pathway regulation. That's a pretty good theory where the sensory gating is bad. And so, you know, information that should be filtered out is not. And so you get this powerful intuition. And that indirect pathway, it's kind of in people that are more mystical and eccentric, you know, maybe more likely to be on the autism spectrum, but also to have a dopamine disorder that these sort of should go fit together. I mean, that'd be one way
来做这件事，就是让临床医生去感受这些东西，看看你用什么来治疗这些东西，如果你用同样的方式治疗很多东西，也许它们是相关的。你可以用主观的方式发现事物。但你还需要用定性研究来取代定量主导。我认为荟萃分析中的数字是导致很多这些过程走向错误的原因，因为如果他们不能在数字中找到它，如果他们不能在那些数字中找到它，那么他们就认为它不是真的。而且有很多事情你永远不会在荟萃分析中看到，但你
to do it is to kind of get clinicians to feel this stuff out and see what are you treating this stuff with and if you're treating a lot of things the same way, maybe they're related. You could discover things in subjective ways. But then you also need to replace quantitative dominance with qualitative study. I think the numbers in the meta-analysis is what's leading a lot of these processes into the words, because if they can't find it into the numbers, if they can't find it in those numbers, then they just don't think it's real. And there's just a lot of things that you're never going to see on a meta-analysis that you
会在治疗中看到，如果你做了三年。你会看到你在电子表格上永远看不到的模式。我很抱歉，但你会的。目前，该领域的智慧被锁在这些利润付费墙、这些私人笔记和孤立的治疗师后面。我们需要一个临床实践的维基百科。我们需要一个开源的、高质量的访问，它不是超级昂贵的，因为像我这样收入的人根本无法支付每月800到900美元来订阅这些巨大的图书馆，但我们却被要求在实践中遵循它。所以我就像借用我朋友的登录名，试图弄清楚如何，你知道，做一个图书馆，你知道，为我想要的这些论文做记录请求。
will see in therapy if you do it for three years. years. You will see patterns that you will never see on a spreadsheet. I'm sorry, but you will. And currently, the wisdom of the field is locked behind these profit paywalls, these private notes and isolated therapists. And we need a Wikipedia of clinical practice. Like, we need an open source, high quality access that isn't super expensive because people that make what I make are just not going to be able to pay $8,900 a month to subscribe to these giant libraries, yet we're supposed to follow it in space practice. So I'm like borrowing my friend's login and trying to figure out how to, you know, do a library, you know, records request for these papers that I want
如果你坚持做三年治疗，你就会看到一些模式，那是你在电子表格中永远无法看到的。抱歉，但事实确实如此。目前，该领域的智慧被锁在这些高昂的付费墙、私人笔记和孤立的治疗师手中。我们需要一个临床实践的“维基百科”。我们需要一种开源、高质量且价格亲民的获取途径，因为像我这样收入水平的人，根本负担不起每月8900美元的巨型图书馆订阅费，但我们却被要求遵循所谓的循证实践。所以我只能借用朋友的账号，试图弄清楚如何为我想要的这些论文申请图书馆记录查询。
to read. And there should be a way to share kind of qualitative data easily that's open source that doesn't give total ownership of it to a company to just profit off of your work where you could retain ownership, but also share it, retain a patent. opportunity without, you know, things like that would benefit the communication in the field in a way that we just, we don't seem to have anymore. And then fourth, I think that we should teach philosophy and narrative and neuroscience in graduate schools. I think that therapists need more neuroscience than they get because they're talking about
阅读。应该有一种简单的方式来分享定性数据，这种方式应该是开源的，而不是让一家公司完全拥有这些数据，从而仅仅从你的工作中获利。你应该能够保留所有权，同时分享它，保留专利机会，而无需……你知道，诸如此类的事情将以一种我们似乎不再拥有的方式造福该领域的交流。第四，我认为我们应该在研究生院教授哲学、叙事和神经科学。我认为治疗师需要的神经科学知识比他们目前得到的要多，因为他们在谈论
polyvagal theory in these neurological concepts, but a lot of times they're using them wrong. You know, I went out and learned this stuff and took classes on it and got downloaded lectures and everything, and I'm not an expert, but I know enough because I need to know it for my job, but we don't get it in school. And it was just sort of, it's never like they were like, you have to learn philosophy because you're going to be a therapist in like 1940 or something. But they just sort of assume that people of that station would have absorbed these things
多迷走神经理论和这些神经学概念，但很多时候他们用错了。你知道，我出去学习了这些东西，上了相关课程，下载了讲座等等，我不是专家，但我知道得足够多，因为我的工作需要，但我们在学校里学不到这些。这从来都不是说，他们会像1940年那样说，你必须学习哲学，因为你要成为一名治疗师。但他们只是假设那个职位的人会吸收这些东西，
that were what we call the liberal arts, the humanities, and the philosophy and some anthropology and sociology. They just assumed that you would like be versed in the liberal arts if you were going to be in a human field. That's not true anymore. So we need to build that into the curriculum because you do need it to do this work. And then fifth, you know, and most importantly probably we had to replace that functional criterion with a suffering criterion. Psychology should exist to reduce human suffering, not to optimize human productivity. And so I think that path forward is about choosing between science and narrative. And it's about realizing that science is a narrative. And it's the greatest, most
也就是我们所说的博雅教育、人文科学、哲学以及一些人类学和社会学。他们只是假设如果你要从事人类领域的工作，你就会精通博雅教育。现在情况并非如此。所以我们需要将其纳入课程，因为你确实需要它来完成这项工作。第五，你知道，可能最重要的是，我们必须用痛苦标准取代功能标准。心理学的存在应该是为了减少人类的痛苦，而不是为了优化人类的生产力。所以我认为前进的道路是在科学和叙事之间做出选择。并且要意识到科学本身就是一种叙事。它是最伟大、最
complex and most rigorous study that we've ever tried to tell and I don't want to attack science here I want to tell its story better I want it to be more scientific we often treat mathematics as if it were this bedrock of reality itself but the numbers are not what's real so you know like this is a time where we're going into this unhealthy place where there's all this pseudoscience that is replacing medicine basically because medicine in general is alienating so many people. Either they don't have the money to afford it, the insurance to pay for it,
复杂且最严谨的研究，是我们曾经尝试讲述过的，我不想在这里攻击科学，我想更好地讲述它的故事，我希望它更科学。我们经常把数学当作现实本身的基石，但数字并不是真实存在的。所以，你知道，这是一个我们正在走向不健康境地的时刻，所有的伪科学基本上都在取代医学，因为医学总体上让太多人感到疏远了。要么他们没有钱负担，没有保险支付，
or they don't have access to it, or they can't navigate the field because they have bad experiences with it. But lots of reasons we're alienating people who I would like to bring towards science. But what's happening is they're running into pseudoscience because they're getting alienated. And so a lot of people are like, I don't want to critique this because maybe there's some problems with it,
或者他们无法获得医疗服务，或者他们无法驾驭这个领域，因为他们有糟糕的经历。但有很多原因让我们疏远了那些我想要带向科学的人。但正在发生的事情是，他们因为感到被疏远而转向了伪科学。所以很多人说，我不想批评这个，因为也许它有一些问题，
but don't throw the baby out with the bathwater. you're going to drive people towards pseudoscience if you tell them there's problems in health care. That's like the missionary argument to me. I mean, some of the more horrific sexual abuse places that you see are these sort of like places that are driven to do like missionary work because they're in this place and they're like,
但不要把孩子和洗澡水一起倒掉。如果你告诉他们医疗保健有问题，你就会把人们推向伪科学。对我来说，这就像传教士的论点。我的意思是，你看到的一些更可怕的性虐待场所，就是那些因为处于这种境地而被迫进行传教工作的场所，他们会说，
well, we can't admit that there's a problem because we're the city on the hill here and we came to minister to people and set a good example. And so we got to cover it up and pray it away and find some way to minimize it and repress it because we can't admit there's a problem because we're here to represent the good, whatever. And when you're saying I can't criticize my profession, because if I criticize it, I'm discrediting it, you're discrediting it when you don't criticize it and everyone knows you're lying.
好吧，我们不能承认有问题，因为我们是山上的城市，我们来这里是为了服务人民并树立好榜样。所以我们必须掩盖它，祈祷它消失，并找到某种方法来最小化和压制它，因为我们不能承认有问题，因为我们在这里代表善良，等等。当你对自己说我不能批评我的职业，因为如果我批评它，我就是在诋毁它，那么当你因为不批评它而让每个人都知道你在撒谎时，你就是在诋毁它。
Or everyone thinks that you're dishonest or that you're blind or that you're naive or whatever. You alienate people when you can't have these conversations. And you don't have to pick between the DSM and Crystal Healing on TikTok. You can point out problems with both of those things. And like before the people who write me, write me and say they work so hard at their PhD, they care so much, they help so many people. Remember that cult leaders think that too. Okay. Like people put enormous work into these belief structures that are not tied to science.
或者每个人都认为你不诚实，或者你盲目，或者你天真，等等。当你无法进行这些对话时，你就会疏远人们。你不需要在DSM（精神疾病诊断与统计手册）和TikTok上的水晶疗法之间做出选择。你可以指出这两者的问题。就像在那些写信给我的人写信说他们为博士学位付出了多少努力，他们有多关心，他们帮助了多少人之前，请记住邪教领袖也这么想。好吧。就像人们在这些与科学无关的信仰结构上投入了巨大的努力一样。
So can you. So can I. And it's our job as humans to interrogate that impulse not to pretend that it isn't there because we're good people who work hard and believe serious things. Everybody thinks that, dude. Everybody thinks that about themselves. You know, people believe things because they believe them for a long time. And they defend them because they're traditional and they're old and they have a history. Well, I just told you this history.
所以你可以。我也可以。作为人类，我们的工作是审视这种冲动，而不是假装它不存在，因为我们是努力工作并相信严肃事物的善良的人。每个人都这么想，伙计。每个人都对自己这么想。你知道，人们相信某些事情是因为他们相信了很长时间。他们捍卫它们是因为它们是传统的、古老的，并且有历史。好吧，我刚才告诉了你这段历史。
What do you think about it? And half the time I make an argument like this, people start telling me how this system works, how the committees work, what they look at. I know the process. I know the history. That's why I think that there's a problem with it. Don't explain to me how it works. Like that makes me go, oh, okay. Well, if they have a committee, fine.
你怎么看？有一半的时间，当我提出这样的论点时，人们开始告诉我这个系统是如何运作的，委员会是如何运作的，他们看重什么。我知道这个过程。我知道这段历史。这就是为什么我认为它有问题。不要向我解释它是如何运作的。那只会让我觉得，哦，好吧。好吧，如果他们有一个委员会，那很好。
No. Like academia is not an exception. to these things any more than a TikTok influencer. And if you don't believe that, go Google like what are the biggest scandals in academia 10 years before now? Because you'll find out what everyone did wrong when they no longer are stakeholders in the thing. Right. They're not going to sell on themselves right now.
不。学术界并不比TikTok网红更能免受这些事情的影响。如果你不相信，去谷歌搜索一下10年前学术界最大的丑闻是什么？因为你会发现当他们不再是利益相关者时，每个人都做错了什么。对吧。他们现在不会出卖自己。
But there's huge problems with academic research in every error. And there are now too. We are not an exception to history. And so like the DSM5, you know, look at high top, look at the hierarchical. taxonomy of psychopathology. I mean, that's a better system with it as P factors. And they are a general factor of psychopathology. And they represent this overall susceptibility.
但在每个时代，学术研究都存在巨大的问题。现在也是如此。我们不能例外于历史。所以就像DSM-5，你知道，看看HiTOP，看看精神病理学的分层分类法。我的意思是，那是一个更好的系统，有P因子。它们是精神病理学的一个通用因子。它们代表了这种整体的易感性。
And like I was talking about with schizophrenia or what became the psychotic disorder. And they also look at spectra. So these broad dimensions, the intersection of these things, like where these symptoms come together around certain nodes, but not even putting them on a line like a spectrum and not putting them on a checklist. That's probably a more useful way to study. That's probably a more neuroscientifically and cognitive science evidence-based psychology. I think we need to bring more neuroscience. We need to bring more cognitive science into psychotherapy in a way that that specialization of academia resists. And those are my conclusions. I think, you know, that if we're
就像我之前谈到的精神分裂症或后来演变成的精神病性障碍。他们也关注谱系。所以这些广泛的维度，这些事物的交叉点，比如这些症状在某些节点周围汇集的地方，甚至不把它们放在像谱系这样的线上，也不把它们放在检查清单上。这可能是一种更有用的研究方式。这可能是一种更符合神经科学和认知科学证据的心理学。我认为我们需要引入更多的神经科学。我们需要将更多的认知科学引入心理治疗，以一种学术界的专业化所抵制的方式。这些就是我的结论。我认为，你知道，如果我们
we don't offer a therapy that is narrative and deeply relational, will continue to lose patience to those who do, even if that person is a pseudoscience influencer that's offering them a lie, because they're still telling them a story. And I'm telling you, I'm reading this book. I don't know what the story is. I don't know what the assumptions are. I don't know what they want me to do with the information. I think they published it because they got a huge committee together and they had a fight and then they published a book. And that's not a very good story. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
不提供一种叙事性和深度关系性的治疗，我们将继续失去那些寻求治疗的患者，即使那个人是一个提供谎言的伪科学网红，因为他们仍然在给他们讲故事。我告诉你，我正在读这本书。我不知道故事是什么。我不知道假设是什么。我不知道他们想让我用这些信息做什么。我想他们出版它是因为他们召集了一个庞大的委员会，他们吵了一架，然后出版了一本书。那不是一个很好的故事。谢谢。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。